Okay.
We're good.
Yeah.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
please welcome Peter Boghossian.
Hello.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks for doing that.
Appreciate it man.
I good.
I think I found out about you through
Sam Harris.
I'm not sure,
but,
uh,
you're also friends with my friend rory
singer.
Oh,
Roy,
he's a great guy.
Great Guy.
He got excited when he found out that
you were coming on.
Roy,
of course,
uh,
martial artists,
a former UFC fighter.
Right.
And,
uh,
kept me many times.
I'm sure he taught me many times too.
So you,
you're,
uh,
you,
you work at,
um,
University of Portland State,
Portland state.
Yeah.
Work Portland state,
teach philosophy there.
And you're also a guy who is your,
you described as an atheism advocate,
like not just an atheist,
but someone who actively promotes,
hey,
you should probably try this.
Um,
I promote critical thinking and reason
and rationality and I,
and the two go together.
Yeah.
And I think that naturally leads to to
atheism if people are honest with
themselves.
And,
um,
and you know,
you mentioned rory.
Uh,
I've been a longtime martial arts my
whole life actually.
Really?
What did you start off with?
The fantasy based martial arts?
The bullshit.
Like which ones?
Uh,
I did everything.
I mean I did,
I tried Kempo I tried,
I literally tried if you were to put all
of the emotional arts together that
don't work and put them into one suite,
I tried them,
all of them.
Well Campos got some good striking
techniques.
They just don't have a,
an overall comprehensive system to deal
with grappling.
Yeah,
I tried [inaudible] I tried taekwondo.
I tried,
uh,
I tried tai cheese so I tried them all.
And then I actually,
one of my turning points was when Ron
van Cleef,
who was in the original UFC as early
UFC,
he was in like ufc three or four or
something like that early on.
And he was like in his fifties he was
older.
He's in still in very good shape.
He,
he liked competed in a tournament,
a karate tournament I think deep into
his sixties.
Yeah,
I trained with,
with Ron and I trained with this guy,
she on Hector Santiago who was quite
something and I trained with them for
years in New York City.
And when Ron van cleef got taken down
and just dominated,
that was a huge moment for me.
That was then I then that started me on
this whole other path.
And then I trained with Greg Jackson for
New Mexico.
Will you in New Mexico?
Yeah.
W having there,
I've trained,
I started in New York City before the
UFC came,
came along and I trained there and then
I trained in New Mexico and now I train
with Matt Thornton from straight blast.
Uh,
his John Calvin,
ours coach who's obviously conor
mcgregor and,
and Nelson's that's,
that's a great lineage man.
So you saw Ron van cleave get dominated
by hoists,
gracie?
Yeah,
like fairly easily.
It was kind of interesting watch like a
guy
who is this ledge really,
really well respected in the karate.
We're whole legend.
Legend.
Smoked like a beginner.
Yeah.
And I saw those guys,
like I saw Hector Santiago fight in real
life and he is a very dangerous person.
You saw him fight like in a street
fighter.
So I used to live in the lower east side
between a and B and a d.
So,
so all of this,
this was just part of my,
my experience and I thought a lot of
this stuff was real and it just turned
out to be fantasy.
It just turned out to be make-believe.
Well,
I think that's an interesting parallel.
When we were talking before the podcast,
we're talking about critical thinking
and Brazilian Jujitsu and martial arts
in general,
and there are a lot of people that have
very distorted ideas of many things,
not just of their ability to handle
themselves physically,
but just of the world in general.
And I think martial arts sort of
highlights a lot of that curriculum,
those critical thinking issues.
Yeah,
and I think that's,
that's one of the reasons that I was so
excited to come on this podcast today is
because I think you are ideally situated
to have it have that conversation with
me because Jujitsu,
Brazilian Jujitsu,
specifically alive in his training,
training against resisting opponents,
we don't talk about,
this is a huge area that nobody is
talking about.
We can understand all of reason and
rationality through Jujitsu,
through corrective mechanisms,
through aligning your beliefs with
reality.
I mean little things from,
you know,
testing ideas yourself,
not having to take it on faith.
I just talking to 'em as talking to uh,
uh,
cause the name eludes me now.
I think,
I think that there's something Chris
harder I think is super good guy.
Great Guy.
Yeah.
There's something in the process.
So,
so you've been tapped thousands of
times.
Sure.
Um,
probably if I counted them all up yet,
I've been tapped to do something about
the type of person who would either if
you frame it in terms of subjecting
yourself to that,
there's something about that that's
fundamentally differentiates us,
if you will,
from people in fantasy based martial
arts.
It develops a kind of character,
develops a kind of attitude when you
placed yourself in situations and get
tapped.
It's,
it's a type of a corrective mechanism.
Jujitsu is a corrective mechanism.
It can help you align your beliefs with
reality.
And,
and I,
I'd love to explore that with you today
and talk about what that means just in
the case that some people might not know
what that means.
We mean by tap is submit.
Um,
when you do Jujitsu,
I believe it or not,
I've talked to,
I assume that people know what we're
talking about,
but I've talked to people go,
okay,
what is Jujitsu?
Like what are you doing?
What?
Submission?
Grappling,
which has a Jujitsu is one style of it,
but it's all about using leverage and
technique,
uh,
against joints or chokes against
arteries like choke holds,
uh,
to cut off the blood to your brain or
neck cranks.
And when you train Jujitsu as opposed to
other martial arts other than wrestling,
which I consider martial art,
you can go full speed on that.
You Go,
you go 100%.
And that's the difference between those
martial arts and striking based martial
arts where you really shouldn't go 100%
because you only have so many punches
your head can take before your body just
stops working.
That's just a fact.
You could train sparring hard for,
you know,
a certain amount of years,
but you're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're mind is going to turn into mush.
There's just no doubt about it.
We know that for a fact.
And people do Jujitsu into their sixties
and yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well Anthony Bordain didn't even start
until he was 58 and he's obsessed.
He trains every day.
He goes sometimes twice a day I'll take
a private in the morning and then he'll
train in a group class after that.
He's a maniac.
Um,
but the difference being like you
absolutely know what works and doesn't
work and you absolutely know how good
people are.
So if we rolled,
you can't fake it.
Yeah.
If we rolled 20 times and you tapped me
18 of those 20 times,
you know,
and if someone said,
how good is Peter?
I'm like,
he taps me most of the time.
And then we know we have no,
they all,
you sit in that case.
But yeah.
Well,
you know what I'm saying?
We know it's clear.
Yeah.
And so you can't fake it.
There's no pretending.
There's no bullshit.
But I know like bowing rituals and
masters and all this nonsense,
all of those structures I think are put
in place to conceal the underlying
paucity of the effectiveness of the
techniques.
And people come up with this.
So the other thing about that that that
I think is so important is that all of
these combat based martial arts,
I've been waiting for this conversation
for all of those combat,
these combat based martial arts.
Let's take a look at,
you mentioned wrestling.
We know it works.
We know there are some things we just
know that they work.
We know the kickboxing works.
We also know that it's head trauma for
kickboxing.
We know that Moitai,
which is in my opinion and insane
activity,
but we know that it works.
We know that Western boxing works.
We know that Jujitsu works,
so the reason that we know we can test
these things,
we can take people and hopefully later
on we'll talk about the difference
between Brazilian Jujitsu and Japanese
Jujitsu,
right?
Same techniques,
different pedagogy,
different training method.
That's a $2 word for training method.
We can take that.
We can adjudicate these things because
we take two people of equal weight and
we stick them in a cage and we have some
very basic rules and also for your
listeners who aren't from there,
mma gloves are very thin.
You know,
I think people who don't understand mma,
they think that they're kind of like
boxing gloves.
They are very,
very thin gloves that they don't afford
much protection at all.
Really led the person punch you harder
so they don't have to worry about
breaking their hand.
But as far as like cushion to your brain
or your head,
yeah,
they're not a cushioning.
Yeah.
So,
so we can look,
we can judge what works.
And the one of the ways that we do that
is to people same size,
put them in a cage and we see what
works.
The other thing is that when you train
against a resisting opponent,
and I think this is the key,
you can figure out what's real.
Like that's a mechanism.
It's a corrective mechanism.
It's a way for you to discern,
make,
believe land and reality.
Bullshit,
reality.
You know,
w what,
what works and what doesn't work.
And once we start introducing that in
systems like,
look,
let's say that I said to you,
Hey,
I've,
I've come up with this technique.
Uh,
I know this is going to sound crazy,
but it's incredibly effective.
And you say,
what is it?
And I say,
it's a pinky blitz creek.
I got a lot like they're gonna use it.
And so I said this,
they said,
well,
attacking with pink.
Yeah.
I say,
you know,
but it's a certain,
stance and I do this right.
You know,
come Bantus stance where,
and you said,
really?
And so you call up,
unbeknownst to me,
you call up,
you know,
like I heard her show you're buddies
with Eddie Bravo right now he's called
me and say,
look,
we got this guy in here.
He says that he has this technique,
p picky blitzkrieg I'm going to send
them over there,
put them up against your good purple
belt,
getting on video and we'll see what
happens.
So it's,
it's a way to test it now.
Now if that works,
you'd be like,
Holy Shit.
Like I can't,
this is awesome.
Like we,
nobody ever thought of the pinky
blitzkrieg it's incredible.
But what you've done there is you,
that's a core component of critical
thinking.
It's a willingness to revise your
beliefs.
It may sound like bullshit,
but you're completely open to the
possibility.
If this works against a resisting
opponent,
right?
So let's say that I tap out his tap out
his,
uh,
purple belts,
and you're like,
all right,
well,
Brown belt.
At some point,
it would be so absurd that you'd think
that Eddie and I were in on it,
right?
I don't know the guy,
I've never rolled them,
never met him.
So He'd call someone else,
but,
and then you can test it so you can
watch it.
Eventually you can test it with your
friends.
So this idea of testability and people
can figure out things for themselves.
They don't have to go on the history of
the tradition.
You know,
some guy punched a bull in the head or
there was a blind nun walking through
this and she killed all these guys.
But that's when we always had to deal
with that was that was the history of
martial arts was always muscle yama and
killed a bull with a banshee.
We always hear about Maslow Yama.
Who was this?
Was He kilkee Shin or I think it was
coke cushion.
Right?
So his lineage,
I don't,
I don't remember,
but he was a famous Japanese guy who
apparently had killed a bull right
punch.
Which,
uh,
and then that,
that,
that comes down as legends.
So when people said,
well,
you know,
how do you know this works?
Why should do it?
Well,
this guy killed a bull.
did you see the bull did,
did you see it?
So,
so it's uh,
it's a fable and the fable takes on a
life of its own.
And the,
the,
the genius about the ultimate fighting
challenge was then you had a way to test
ideas,
right?
You can literally watch these things
unfold against people of,
in
the early ones,
your people have different weight
classes.
They had the sumo wrestler and the
kickboxing guy.
So,
but not only that,
it was an opportunity for you to figure
out what was real,
right?
And there's something that's incredibly
appealing to that.
Like think about,
think about Kata,
right?
What a fucking waste of time.
Like not only is it a waste of time in
terms of let's say what Kata is,
it's like,
you want to go.
Yeah.
And so it's,
we'll their forms and what a form as
it's like a pattern of movement that
you,
that everyone does.
You'd get one when you get your white
belt,
you practice that and you get really
good at it.
You do it for a task to get your yellow
belt.
And in a lot of traditional martial
arts,
that is part of how you test.
You know,
I,
I got my black belt in taekwondo and I
had to remember all those goofy moves
and they never came into play ever.
When I competed they were,
there were no sort of nonsense.
It was a waste of time.
And as soon as I did get my black,
I forgot all of them,
barely remember it.
It's a waste of time.
But I'd argue it's even worse than a
waste of time.
If it were just a waste of time,
then you know,
you could have been staring at a wall,
but you thought that you were doing
something to help you achieve a goal and
the goal was to win a fight.
So you thought you were engaged in
activity,
that the whole,
there's no resisting opponent.
So when there's no resisting opponent,
it's not a tea,
it's not testable.
You can't bring the tools of science
too.
Right.
So,
so you thought you were engaging in
activity that brought you closer to your
desired objectives,
but it didn't.
Here's the argument against that though.
The what it does do is it helps your
precision movement and you could argue
that learning how to execute these
patterns in a very beautiful way shows
control and it,
and it shows precision movement.
They aren't,
the problem with it is that there's some
of those movements that are completely
ineffective like double knife,
hand block or thrusts,
knife hand thrusts is,
there's movements that are there,
the not applicable to mma.
But the concept behind it is actually
something that a lot of really good
mixed martial arts like Carlos condit or
even conor mcgregor are doing.
They're doing a lot of like movement
training.
And um,
although I don't think Kata is the best
way to achieve those kinds of goals.
Yeah,
I think that there's something to be
said for not just martial arts
techniques,
but other things as well.
Like Yoga I think is extremely effective
in enhancing your ability to,
um,
to control and manage your body in the
movements.
All right.
She's a weird strength.
So we're on the same page.
So think about it.
I'd offer a constructive way to think of
it like this.
So what you just said,
I don't know anything about basketball.
So I'm going to just use basketballs
stamp.
There's a ball and a net and black eyes
and then that's
the court.
So,
so,
so I'm like guys,
when when you think about basketball,
what you just described was a guy on a
court practicing a lay up over and over
again.
I think a layup is like when you bounce
it and you shoot,
you don't know the law.
I don't know anything about basketball.
So I'm like your run up to the fan,
you run,
throw the ball and then whole and
everybody gets crazy.
Okay.
But think about,
don't think about caught.
So you,
so I think thinking about caught to like
a layup in terms of precision is the
wrong way to look at,
look at it.
Think about Catia as a layup without a
basketball.
Think about the practice of basketball
practice,
quote unquote a basketball without a
basketball.
Right.
Okay,
here's the problem with that.
What about shadow boxing?
Shadow boxing is extremely effective and
shadow boxing in a sense is a form of
Kata shadow boxing and w including not
just boxing but kicking and punching and
needing is a long,
long excepted.
Excellent form of training and
visualization.
Yeah.
So,
so one of the things that shadow boxing
you can do,
you can warm up was shadow boxing.
When I,
when I woke up in Git and just to be
upfront,
I,
I suck.
I've been doing it for a long time,
but I'm not very good.
I just felt or I love it.
Blue Belt.
So I'm not how long you've been doing.
I'm not,
I'm tell you it'd be ambassador.
Tell me since 1999 how dare you,
you're still a blue belt.
Um,
how often do you do it?
Well only once a week if I'm lucky.
Oh,
okay.
You gotta go Anthony Bourdain's tag.
You got to get obsessed.
Yeah.
I just don't have a lot of
opportunities.
Like I have a family that I pushed
forward.
I have a work career and I have either
you have a life,
a life.
Yeah.
I'm fucking people with their lives.
So you know I'm not,
I'm not speaking about it from any kind
of like,
you know,
I'm an expert in this.
I understand what you're saying.
But I think what's interesting about
this is the philosophical implications.
And so like,
like when I woke up,
I like to warm up with another body to
slow roll,
you know,
I like to just,
because then I have an opponent.
If you're practicing something over and
over again,
the problem with that is there's no
corrective mechanism.
You could be doing the technique
incorrectly and then when you actually
go to execute it,
you've had a body memory for that
technique that hasn't,
that's been,
that's taking you away from your goal.
Do you mean with striking you mean mean
shadowbox and when you use these samples
shadowboxing,
just so you're saying with shadow boxing
that you,
you need another body in order for it to
be effective.
No,
I'm saying that like,
so let's say that you shadow box a
hammer punch.
Okay,
so stuff that doesn't work like Catia,
things like double knife hands.
If you,
even if you,
if you a shadowbox jabs and crosses and
upper cuts and stuff,
even if you do that,
if you could not be doing it correctly
and then you'd be practicing the wrong
thing over and over again and that will
take you away from your goal.
That's why you need,
you have to have some kind of a
resisting opponent.
Resisting
opponents are the corrective mechanisms
for everything and just as the,
they're the correct of mechanisms in the
physical domain.
Did the corrective mechanisms in the
cognitive and intellectual domains as
well.
That's why prayer is so insidious.
It's because people think that they're,
they're doing something that's in their
own wellbeing.
They're doing something that's good,
but they're just talking to themselves.
But there is some aspects and I would
agree with,
I don't know if I would,
I don't like labels.
I have a real hard time with labels,
even labels for things that I think are
good things like I think that some
people get a lot out of prayer and not
necessarily because they're praying to a
nonexistent deity or they really truly
believe that if they wish for a new car
it's going to come to them,
but I think that the mind when focused
on positive thinking and and and focused
on love and focused on that,
the tenants of Christianity let go of
God godly behavior and compassion and
all these different things and you truly
are looking out for your fellow man and
wanting to be a good person.
All those things.
I think there is merit in that.
I think you can,
you can,
you can certainly find benefit in that
as a tool for mental management.
I mean does that mean there's a guy in
the clouds with a harp and all that
jazz?
Of course not,
but I think that it's in a sense like
like Tai Chi.
I mean,
if a guy thinks that he's going to take
Tai Chee only and get into the UFC,
uh,
it's hilarious.
He's going to get fucked up.
But if a guy in the UFC,
like conor mcgregor for instance,
who's so concentrated on movement really
gets involved in Tai Chi,
I think he would probably get at least
some benefit out of it because in that
slow moving,
this like rhythmic pattern,
what you're doing is you're exercising
your body in an unusual way and
expanding the possibilities of,
of your,
your,
your interactions with opponents,
expanding what your body can and can't
do.
And I think yoga does that.
I think there's a lot of different
things.
So we need that.
There are about 20 really interesting
things that you just said.
I think we need to kind of unpack those
a little bit.
Like,
so if you talk about you to take a look
at prayer and what people think that
they're doing,
and then let's,
this is why you're the perfect person is
talking to this about,
uh,
then compare that to a martial art.
That's bullshit,
right?
Like Tai Chi is a good example.
Okay,
so people think that they're going
towards a certain end winning fights.
It's certainly,
I don't know about now anymore,
but certainly some people that teach Tai
Chi and even practice Tai Chi that are
just doing it for their health.
Yeah.
My Dad is one of those people,
so he has zero ambitions to win a fight
with anybody.
He's in his late seventies so if
somebody says that,
I have no problem with that at all and I
think it's true in Mo motion
would be better than non motion and the
prom is exactly the same problem with
religion.
When people are making objective claims,
they're making claims about the nature
of reality and I want to know what's
true and we don't even,
the problem is that people,
every time you talk about faith,
the religion or have you people shut
down or they have barriers,
we don't need to talk about that.
All we need to do is talk about Jujitsu.
That's why this is so perfect because
with Jujitsu you can figure things out
yourself with,
you can figure out what works,
right?
The pinky blitzkrieg you can figure out
what doesn't work.
You can figure out what you're capable
of.
If,
if I tap you,
if,
if you tap me out 20 times,
I'm under no illusions that the 21st
time,
I mean I could get lucky,
you know,
like I could get lucky against rory,
I could get lucky against Matt Thornton.
It's always possible I could get,
it's highly unlikely,
but I could get lucky.
The problem is that if you look at the
way that people engage these rituals in
their lives,
what these people are doing is it,
they think it's taking them towards an
end.
It's exactly identical to fantasy based
martial arts.
They think it's taking them towards an
end.
It's not right.
I think also a parallel like in fantasy
based martial arts,
the benefits of it.
Like
I was,
like I said,
I did taekwondo for a long time and uh,
I got really good at it and then
competed a lot.
And uh,
I was essentially in a cult.
I mean,
taekwondo a,
although it's a beneficial called and it
helped me a lot and it made a lot of
ways and made me the person that I am
today because in training and doing
really difficult things and competing
and overcoming nerves and all that
stuff,
there's a lot of benefit in it.
But then,
um,
I had a distorted perception of reality
because of it.
And that distorted perception of reality
was shattered once I started boxing.
Exactly.
And I realize like,
oh my God,
I was getting punched in the face.
I didn't know.
I thought I knew how to fight when
really I just knew how to do taekwondo.
Right.
And then I had to learn all the other
aspects of martial arts.
Like one of the most sobering moments of
my life was when I,
I trained at Carlson Gracie's in,
um,
on,
on Hawthorne,
in Hollywood in 1996.
And this is before Vito Belfort made his
debut in the UFC.
And,
uh,
I,
you know,
I had this long,
extensive history of competing and
taekwondo tournament and I had kicked
boxed and,
uh,
I'd done quite a bit of a boxing
training and a,
I wrestled in high school.
I thought it was pretty good martial
artist and I just got fucking mall.
So like I had never exercised.
Like I had no idea what I was doing.
And I just remember the feeling of
helplessness and the guy who,
one of the,
I mean,
a bunch of people mauled me,
but one of the guys at mauled me I'll
never forget,
is this Brazilian kid who was a purple
belt who was basically my size.
He wasn't any bigger than me.
And he wasn't like some Super Mario
Sperry blackbelt guy.
Yeah.
He
was just some guy just beat the fuck out
of me.
I mean,
he's almost disdainfully and he was a
nice guy,
but I mean,
when he was training,
he was training really hard and he
didn't give me any slack.
It was just getting wrecked.
And I remember thinking,
wow,
what a stupid illusion I was under.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and so in a sense,
I think it's,
I mean,
I guess that's a question we could talk
about,
but I know is it incumbent upon us to
help people out of these traditional
martial arts?
Like I did a,
I had a very similar experience.
I trained in stick a knife fighting for
years.
That's why my hands cuts.
Yes.
Grima that's why my my hands have all
these cuts and are all married with real
knives,
real knives and sticks.
Yeah.
I did the stuff with the dog brothers
and Dan Medina was,
I've got a black belt and stick a knife
fighting and,
and you know,
I'm thinking about black belts and
sticking a knife.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I mean,
if you're in a place where the bullets
are all gone and no one knows how to
make a gun,
well,
bows and arrows haven't been invented.
That's where I was going to go with
this.
Where I was going to go with this is I,
I,
uh,
so I thought it was a pr like you,
I thought I was pretty good martial
artist.
Right.
And then,
uh,
I fought a guy fight,
actually great Jackson with sticks and
just beat the shit on them.
And I mean I had a stick and I had been
training with the stick for like years
at that point.
And it was just a huge wake up call from
you guys fought like in the competition
we fought in like a fight fight and,
and I,
he had only on fight fight.
You were mad at each other?
No,
like uh,
you know,
like a party's arm to the submission.
I mean we were like,
I was not,
so it was a competition?
Well No,
it was at his old place and this is when
I started training with him and we,
I think we put on like very light hockey
gear and I was just going to beat the
shit out of him.
I was just going to,
yeah,
well that was my goal cause he said he
based,
this was before I learned about a
liveliness training and and you know,
resisting.
That's the lifeness.
Yeah.
So that's like Matt Thornton to me and,
and,
and it's a combination of,
that's a whole other discussion.
It's like,
um,
timing,
energy and motion,
resisting opponents,
ways to figure out what's true and what
works.
And I,
uh,
this gets back to our discussion about
shadow boxing and about training other
ways.
I had trained with a stick and I had
known all of these kind of basically
this caught to things,
but I also trained against a willing
opponent.
Like when you watch these stick demos,
the key to to look for is what the UK
does.
The feeder,
you know,
it's not what the guy does.
UK,
I think this is a Japanese word for like
the guy who's feeding in,
you know,
like,
oh,
okay,
so the guy who is,
I do this and that people,
most of the people are listening to
this.
It's like probably 90%,
even though a lot of watching it.
So what,
what you're demonstrating for those who
are listening is like,
there's,
um,
these live,
these drills that you do where someone
will pretend to throw a punch gifts so
the person will step aside and do their
counter attack and it looks awesome.
So the UK guy has it.
Got We in taekwondo,
he used to call it the one steps.
Yeah.
The one steps.
And,
and it's,
it's a great example of a fantasy based
martial art because it makes you,
it brings you further from reality.
It makes you think you can do something
that you simply cannot do.
So what you need to do in those
circumstances is you need to watch the
feed or the person who's giving the
reverse punch.
It's like punched that comes off of
your,
I'm trying to be caught a punch that
comes off of your ribs and goes out and
they almost never hit somebody.
Like if,
if you watched the Steven Seagal when he
got his black belt as a famous black and
white video that's out there and Jamie
can link to it,
I guess.
Uh,
it looks awesome,
but it's bullshit.
It's all choreographed.
The kido.
Yeah.
So,
so the,
the key deliverable I think in this
call,
one of those in this conversation is
that whether it's shadow boxing or
whether it's Kata or whether it's taking
a knife and doing a drill.
When I used to do those train with
sticks,
I was really,
really good.
But I always knew the angle.
So it was fantasy based.
If you took the angle out of it,
I would just get beaten to death.
I mean peeps,
I'm,
what do you mean by angle?
So like in disrobed or scream or there
are 12 angles.
It goes 99 it goes like 75 degrees,
35 degrees the other way.
Baseball swing,
reverse baseball,
swing,
stab,
overhand stab,
tack to the knees,
attack to the other needs.
So when you do,
when you do those,
when you train,
you guys just do the numbers one,
two,
three and you know,
you get so good at it.
I mean it's pretty crazy.
I can show your stuff here.
You know?
It's like if I know the angle,
it looks awesome.
I've seen guys do it.
It looks pretty bad ass,
but it's bullshit.
It's bullshit.
It's fantasy based martial arts because
the opponent isn't resisting.
You have to have a resisting opponent.
But here's the deliverable for this
conversation I think is that if you
train in a certain way,
absent to corrective mechanism,
but you think that corrective mechanism
is an actual corrective mechanism.
In other words,
you think you're training in a way that
will bring you closer to reality,
but you're becoming further from
reality.
What that does is that takes that,
that's just a,
that's devastating because you need that
corrective mechanism.
You need to bring your thoughts in
alignment with reality.
And that was the great thing about the
UFC is because now we have all these
people and we can see what works.
So think about the guys.
You know I,
I listened to your show that he bravo
are I think,
and he said,
you know,
he was just practicing the,
the rear naked on his leg from,
well that's not gonna work because
there's no corrective mechanism because
I don't think you understand what you're
saying.
Well maybe I wasn't,
he was exercising his squeeze on his
leg.
He still does it.
And it's because one of the things about
Jujitsu,
about finishing a technique is how hard
can you squeeze and how long can you
squeeze.
So what Eddie does is he'll do this
like,
well if we're watching TV together,
he'll do it.
He puts his knee up.
If we're watching the fights,
who put his knee up like this and he'll
rear naked,
choke his own knee and just squeeze it.
And what he's doing is he's working on
it,
squeeze and it's not thinking that
that's going to make him get to that
position where he can squeeze someone.
Okay.
Well the or against a live resisting
opponent.
He's,
it's an exercise.
Okay.
So that's cool.
So if,
if the idea then is that we'll work on
your squeeze,
then that's different from thinking
that,
that if,
if I,
if I train,
if you practice,
think about like practicing shadow
boxing and you're to use your example
and your hook is always,
you know,
wide,
you stand here and then when you get
into a fight,
if you deal with a resisting opponent
and you do that,
so you would have,
you would have gone down a path to make
you worse than are,
but that's assuming that you're doing it
incorrectly.
If you train correctly and you learn the
techniques correctly and then you apply
them in your shadow box and correctly
it's going to benefit.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's the question that the question
is,
and I mean the,
the great thing about this conversation
is that we can test this stuff,
right?
I mean this is the ultimate we have,
we have people we have,
so for that we need to look at the,
the only big word I think we need here
today is pedagogy.
Like at the training method,
it's a big word for training method.
We don't even need pedagogy.
Just say training method.
So we look at the training method and
what I think you would need for that is,
well actually I guess here's my question
to you.
Would it be better in your mind to train
shadowboxing or to do some light boxing
with guys with focus middle over there
at guys holding up focus Mitts at the
same speed that you were shadowboxing?
This is where I think the conversation
is going on,
right?
It's not that it's better.
All those things have their merits.
Shadowboxing has its merit.
Yoga has its merit.
Yoga is not going to teach you how to be
a a better fighter,
but if you learn all the techniques of
Jujitsu and you incorporate yoga into
your training,
it will likely elevate your Jujitsu.
There's,
I have absolutely no question that
that's true and I think that that goes
along with shadow boxing.
If you're,
especially if you're a striker,
if you're a striker and you don't
shadowbox,
I think you're doing yourself a
disservice.
I think there is a benefit to a
visualization and to movement.
And two,
there's,
there's things that happen when you
throw combinations in the air.
Um,
as far as you are dexterity,
especially with kicking and your ability
to even do combinations without any
resistance or without anybody,
um,
uh,
trying to counter you,
there's,
there's benefit in stringing together
those reps,
those repetitions.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think there is a benefit of that.
And I think so sometimes if I,
if I go in to straight blast and there's
nobody on the mat,
there's no way to roll with,
sometimes what I'll do is I'll just go
through the motions.
Like I'll do roles or I'll do go over my
back shoulder or I'll just,
you know,
fall down.
There's
merit,
there's merit to that in that,
um,
I think I already know how to do it.
I mean I'm sure sure that I could
improve on it without any question at
all.
Is so like your example of yoga is a
really good one.
I think it's certainly true that you can
use muscles and yoga that you don't,
and another activity.
And I think that those have benefits to
mma.
In fact,
I'm sure they have benefits to a lot of
other things.
So,
so the not just the flexibility aspect
and the body maintenance,
there's a lot of good things to it.
Yeah.
I don't do it myself.
I probably should,
but if I would,
I'd just spend that hour and doing
Jujitsu to be blunt with you.
But I think that you can get things out
of yoga and get things out of these
other activities,
but you have to be conscious about the
reason why you're doing these things and
the way to get better ultimately like,
yeah,
so you could shadow box at a certain
level.
Um,
and again,
I guess I think we can think about it
at,
in terms of the layup example,
again,
it's not necessarily the lay the ball is
the corrective mechanism with the layup.
The person is the corrective mechanism
and the fight.
And as long as somebody knows what
they're doing and their training in a
certain way,
it's not necessarily that shadowboxing,
we'll take one away from one school if
it's being practiced correctly.
I think Carta would take one away from
one school,
but I think that the whole project,
like if you think about,
and that's why I think the shadow boxing
is such a good example of this.
What is it that that w okay,
so when someone's shadow boxes,
the,
the point is to warm up that
accomplishes that.
You could do that with squats to right.
And someone or you know,
you could do that in any one of a number
of,
you're looking at me like you're lost.
No,
no,
that was all in your head,
man.
I just ain't got,
I got,
I got that look like we're just talking
about,
no,
I'm just listening.
Yeah.
Well if you think I'm,
if you think I'm off track,
let me know.
Uh,
you might be a little off track.
Um,
in that I think you think there's very
little benefit and a lot of these
activities that I think a aren't primary
activities.
I think,
yeah,
if you wanted to break it down to what
is the only,
see there's just this broad range of
things you can do,
you could do to improve all sorts of
athletic endeavors.
Like there's a lot of people that don't
believe you should do any strength and
conditioning training.
You should just do technique and you
should just do sparring.
There's a lot of people that go that
route.
And then there's other people that think
that's absolutely foolish you should
primary like,
especially once you learn the skills you
should,
if you're competing,
you should focus primarily on strength
and conditioning because really it's
just about burning your body out and
reaching an incredibly high level of
cardio so that when you compete,
you know all these techniques already,
you will now a gas tank that's superior
to your opponents and that will lead to
victory.
Like there's a lot of modalities and
there's a lot of schools of thought.
Can we talk for a sec?
Can we talk about that for a sec?
Sure.
So it's interesting to me.
I see guys who come in who,
uh,
who are just super strong.
And I think to a certain extent we need
to be careful because strength,
and again,
I'm not speaking from experience so
much,
I'm speaking of just conceptually.
I think there's a tendency for strong
guys or big guys to overlay upon their
strengths or size small man Jiu Jitsu is
the best to just tell people if they're
thinking about learning.
Jujitsu learned from a little person
because little guys,
you know,
boiler Gracie or even Eddie Bravo before
he started lifting weights that he's
quite a bit bigger now,
but Eddie was always like,
you know,
150 pounds,
140 pounds.
So what he was rolling,
he would always be rolling with big guys
and he had to rely on perfect technique.
Whereas a guy like Frank Mir,
who's a very large man,
has a lot of physical strength and they
rely on that.
Yeah.
And I think,
well,
you tell him what you think.
Do you think that if somebody goes in
strong and they focus on that often that
that can come at the expense of learning
techniques?
Yes,
it can.
But here's the problem,
the concept of strength and
conditioning.
A lot of people think,
oh well you're doing squats and dead
lifts.
Um,
a good example is a guy I've had on this
podcast before.
His name is Nick Khorsandi,
Trans Hofeld Osan Joe see trains a
Russell and providing the cough was a
frame famous boxer,
but a lot of world class athletes.
Joe Schilling,
who's a glory to shirt,
I'm wearing a one of their uh,
best fighters,
excellent kickboxer world champion.
What he's doing is his strength and
conditioning program.
He trained under Marvin Marinovich and
nick does a lot of plyometric exercises,
a lot of sprinting,
a lot of box jumps and all these really
unorthodox techniques.
And the idea is to improve your ability
to execute things,
improve your ability to close the
distance and includes your,
improve your ability to get out of the
way and prove your ability to maintain a
high workload through the rounds.
You know,
like if you can only throw,
uh,
let's say 50 kicks in,
around before you get exhausted,
and if you can improve that through
strength,
strength and conditioning,
make it 75 or 80,
you're going to have a significant
advantage over the pace that you can
push on your opponent.
And that is in his opinion and many
other people's opinion.
And this is,
this is a really open debate right now
in the world of martial arts because it
has not been solved because it relies on
so many variables.
It relies on the athlete themselves,
their mental fortitude,
their dedication to their craft.
Um,
how good is their technique in the first
place before they embark on a trunk
strength and conditioning program?
There's so many variables I think to
unbox all this.
Um,
and to make it a little bit easier for
people that are going,
what the fuck are they talking about?
What we're saying is there's a lot of
people that have distorted ideas about
reality itself and a method for exposing
that kind of thinking,
which is like this sort of dogmatic
religious thinking,
which is ultimately accepted by all the
people around you,
but never,
never critically judged.
Yeah.
A really good method is Jujitsu and the,
the meaning,
the reason why Jujitsu is such a good
method is because Jujitsu is one of the
few martial arts that you could practice
at any age and you could apply to.
And you could also watch those
techniques being applied by other
people.
And when,
you know,
gigit like yesterday I went to the Eddie
Bravo invitational,
which was at the orpheum theater in
downtown La,
some of the best Jujitsu fighters in the
world.
We're going at it.
Uh,
and it was really amazing to watch.
It was awesome.
And it was a,
a crowd filled with thousands of people
who are fans of Jujitsu and
practitioners.
So it was really educated crowd.
And what was cool about that is we all
understood like when the guy got to a
position like,
oh,
blah,
blah.
And you know,
the crowd would cheer when someone would
get out of a heel hook or they would
cheer when a guy would be able to tap a
guy with a rear naked choke.
And we were watching all these things
play out.
So there was lessons for me as a,
as someone who's not competing as
sitting in the audience,
because I've spent so much time doing
Jujitsu,
I was watching this sort of,
these interactions take place in a very
logical truth seeking truth seeking
community.
Exactly,
exactly.
I mean,
when the techniques work,
the techniques work.
And by the way,
what's interesting is Brazilian Jujitsu
as it was first created,
or a first sort of established came from
Japanese Jujitsu and Elio Gracie and
Carlos Gracie,
who were probably two of the most
important people ever in the history of
martial arts.
They,
they sort of manipulated those
techniques and improved upon them and
made the art more about the submissions
than it was about the stand up and the
bringing the fight to the ground.
And in doing so,
they established a series of techniques
and you know,
we,
we refer to those techniques as the
basics.
There are some people in that world that
think that the basics are all you need
and they don't accept the new
techniques.
And it's really fascinating because
that's essentially how Jujitsu became
effective in the first place is because
the new techniques that were established
by Carlos and Elio,
Gracie and all these different movements
like the guard,
like learning how to do triangles off
your back,
all these different things,
which people had no idea.
And the early UFC like Royce gracie
tapped out,
dan severn,
everybody's like,
what the fuck is he doing?
He's got his legs wrapped around his
neck and his arm.
What is this?
And then Dan's about to go out and he
taps and everybody's like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
Well those were in our world,
completely new techniques.
Well there's a lot of new techniques
that are constantly being established
now by these young innovative
practitioners and that some of the old
guard are ignoring.
And the real question is,
is that smart?
Do you just need the basics?
And it's a hot debate right now.
But again,
this hot debate can be proven.
That's exactly what I was going to say.
Yes,
that's exactly right.
And if as a result of this being proven,
somebody doesn't change their mind.
So the core piece that what's really
important is belief,
revision,
critical thinking is all about,
I made a mistake.
I was wrong.
I thought this,
you know what,
I,
I made a mistake.
And so if they don't do that,
then they're somehow deficient in that
attitude and disposition of critical
rationality,
you know,
they,
but it would seem to me if it could be
demonstrated,
people who want to seek the truth in
this case,
they want to win against a resisting
opponent.
Some,
some would,
some would accept the data,
but many haven't.
And my good friend Eddie Bravo is a
perfect example of that.
I went with Eddie to Brazil in 2003 and
he competed in the world championships
and he beat,
um,
Gustavo Dante,
who was a world champion at the time.
He tapped him in his first fight.
And then after that he fought boiler
Gracie,
who was one of the greatest Brazilian
jujitsu competitors of all time.
Hoya gracie's a national hero.
They closed the other mats off.
They put a spotlight on the main event
and they thought they thought that
Heuler was going to wreck this young kid
who wasn't even a black belt at the
time.
Eddie was a brown belt.
Okay.
And Eddie with his unorthodox techniques
that people had laughed at tap toilet
gracie in front of everybody and he got
him with the triangle,
but he got up the setup was his rubber
guard set up.
He has all these crazy guards set ups
and you know,
his game has advanced light years since
then.
But the point being that people mocked
him for that,
it didn't help that he went to his next
fight.
He fought Leo Vieira and he popped his
rib early in the fight and got dominated
in that fight and almost got tapped.
But he know there was also a giant
emotional let down because he couldn't
believe he just tapped toilet gracie.
And now,
now he's moving on and he's fighting Leo
Vieira,
who's another monster,
Brazilian Jujitsu,
ours.
But there's a point for the longest time
people,
there was two schools of thought.
There was the old guard that just did
not accept him.
They openly mocked him.
And you know,
the,
the really criticized his whole movement
and his,
his techniques,
what champions is,
he produced all this.
This doesn't really work on real
fighters until he had a rematch with
boiler many years later and just wrecked
him.
I mean,
it was,
it was worse than the first time because
heuler didn't tap,
but he got his knee destroyed.
I mean,
if you watch that video who are just
deals with the fact that his knees
getting ripped apart while Eddie's
mangling it,
but it was never a moment where Eddie
was in trouble.
He dictated the entire match.
And we played the fight on,
uh,
on the TV,
on a,
on a podcast.
And had Eddie explained what he was
doing and even when it looked like
horror,
Lou was improving the position and he
was like,
no,
I let him do that.
So I could do this and then I'll,
then I would adjust and he was like
explaining,
I pulled him back on top of me because
I knew if I did that I would be able to
move his arm higher up on my shoulder.
Then I rolled him back over onto his
back and then I can get deeper in on
when he was explaining that it was even
more humiliating.
Because you've got this guy who earlier
Gracie,
who has a multiple time world champion
who just did not learn these new
techniques,
feels like she's got these old
techniques and that's it.
So this is the application.
That's exactly right.
And if you don't learn it and if you're
not willing to revise your beliefs and
if you're not looking,
if you're not willing to test this and
accept the conclusion,
you know,
you might think something's common
sense.
Common sense is irrelevant.
What's relevant is what works.
Yeah.
Well these new techniques that are
constantly being innovative,
they're constantly changing.
Like it's almost impossible to stay up
on all of it unless it's a monster part
of your life and you're absorbing him
every day.
Like the leg lock game is this new
element that over the last few years has
really come into play in a major way.
Thanks to a bunch of guys,
John,
Donna,
her,
Eddie Cummins,
Gary Tone and who won the Eddie Bravo
and invitation only yesterday.
These like really high level
practitioners and instructors are
constantly adding new improvements to
approaches and techniques.
So it's all a applicable,
it's all you can watch it happen in real
time.
And even as someone who's not competing
like me sitting in the audience,
I understand the positions and the
movements.
So when I see all this new stuff and I
see all these new approaches,
it's like,
wow,
this game just continues to grow and
evolve.
Yeah,
and w what amazes me is when I watched
kids classes,
kids are doing the craziest stuff.
I mean they really have stood on the
shoulders of giants and they're doing
stuff that's just so advanced.
And I look at that now and I think,
wow,
it's like speed.
Even great thing.
How quickly these techniques and this
game has been advanced in a very,
very short period time.
There has literally been,
in my lifetime,
a revolution in the martial arts.
It really has.
I've been saying this for a while,
but I'll say it again.
The UFC has changed martial arts so
radically that there's been more
improvement since 1993 there's been more
evolution than there are.
There have been in the last 10,000
years.
That's real.
That's 100% true.
You go back and watch martial arts from
1993 and watch the UFC today,
it's a completely different realm.
Right?
It's fascinating.
The differences.
Oh,
of course.
When you talk about Jujitsu being
applicable and all its applicable inside
Jujitsu,
the problem is when you get someone
who's a really good wrestler,
who's an awesome kickboxer and you can't
use your Jujitsu,
you're still going to get fucked up.
Like a guy like chuck Liddell who you're
not going to take down and he's going to
knock you dead.
He's a great wrestler.
You mean he's a perfect anti Jujitsu
guy?
Okay.
But even even that,
look at that,
I gave five things that work,
boxing and wrestling with two of the
five.
They train against resisting opponents,
right?
Uh,
so it's no surprise then,
and maybe sometimes he comes from a
Kempo background,
you know,
I mean,
you,
you've listed that it's one of the
martial arts that don't really work,
but that's the martial art that
chocolate Dell learned for striking
under John Hackleman.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I mean,
that's another example.
People can,
like I,
I saw,
I can't,
so you're much more versed in the
specifics than I am,
but I,
sorry,
to burst a gunner Nelson fight and what
she did,
uh,
I think it was,
background hoss to someone's head and
just ground Dick.
He did.
Uh,
no,
he did.
Uh,
I thought he looked around house to
someone's in the back of someone's head.
He trained in traditional karate for
years,
Huh?
Yes.
Yeah.
He's a brown belt in karate.
And so it's not that these techniques
can't be integrated or that they don't
work.
Part of the problem is that they're sold
as systems.
You know,
it's like,
instead of picking and choosing,
so if everybody trained against
resisting opponents,
it's not clear to me that there would be
any styles,
styles would fade away.
Right.
But then,
and then that highlights the problem
that we brought up earlier that you
really can't resist.
You can't train 100% resisting with
kickboxing.
If you want to be a healthy member of
society,
that's brain damage.
I'm pretty sure I have brain damage and
I stopped really getting hit in the head
when I was 22.
I mean,
I really haven't been hitting the head
of that much since then,
but I'm for sure something's fucked up
in there.
Yeah.
I was watching a guy hit the pads about
a brown belt a couple of weeks ago and I
just thought to myself,
I mean he,
the whole thing was moving it and I
thought to myself like,
wow,
like if that guy ever hit me,
Oh yeah.
I mean that would be it.
I mean,
it would just be over and,
and I,
and I watched people kick the heavy bag
sometimes.
Have you ever seen Melvin manhoef kicked
the pads?
Jesus Christ pull up Melvin manhoef
trains with,
uh,
um,
I forgot his trainer's name.
Mike Mike's gym.
And uh,
I forgot how to say his last passenger,
passenger.
I forget how to say it cause he's there.
Dot.
They're a Dutch,
they're from Holland.
But uh,
there's a,
a video is a bunch of videos of Malvin
but Melvin kicking the pads with him.
It's just Scott,
the I'm terrifying cause he's a super
fucking athlete and he's training with
this really aggressive Moitai trainer or
kickboxing trainer.
Mike's gym is famous for like guys like
Badr Hari and,
and um,
man who have that are just fucking
ferocious aggressive competitors.
And manhood is particularly famous for
having just unbelievable knockout power.
He knocked out Mark Hunt and he weighed
185 pounds.
He knocked out Mark Hunt when mark
[inaudible] was probably 300 pounds.
Yeah.
And so imagine some of those guys or
people in their lineage fighting it is
what fighting these guys who do Katas.
There's not pads though.
You gotta focus pads.
See,
see if you can find one with him.
Yeah.
That says,
that's just my,
see if you could find,
um,
Melvin manhood.
That's him though.
That's Melvin.
But they're just sparring there,
which most of the time they,
they go hard.
But,
uh,
they usually don't go too hard to the
head.
Yeah.
That's the Holon style.
So imagine those guys fighting these
guys who are in make believe land.
Oh yeah.
You want your fantasy fantasy land,
right?
We've,
we've played videos many times and
recently one or here's hills.
Malvin see,
get some volume on that shit.
Sounds not saying for some reason,
but you get the picture of him.
He's a fucking destroyed that switch
kick to the body.
Good Lord.
When you watch this guy in real life,
it's even more stunning because you,
you really can feel the impact when he's
kicking the pads.
So the other thing about that is that
guy knows we can do and he can't do,
they don't spend a lot of these young
kids,
they see a movie with a guy who's beaten
up five guys with knives and bats and
stuff.
It's total make believe land and it
immerses people in a culture of make
belief.
Yeah,
I agree.
No,
I couldn't agree more.
And I was in that culture.
I used to teach it.
I taught at Boston University.
I mean,
it's like a big,
big,
huge part of my life.
And,
uh,
the wake up call that I got was,
it was a really stunning thing to just
to end.
It was,
oh,
it was a long progression.
It wasn't just one wake up call.
It was like one wake up call and then
another one,
and then deeper and deeper and deeper.
And then the UFC comes along,
you're like,
oh fuck,
you know,
oh,
this is this.
And then you get this understanding
like,
I live my life under this illusion.
Yeah.
And the other thing that's interesting
to me about that is those are culturally
reinforced,
right?
There are these rituals.
There's the bowing,
the master,
the other people that your friends that
you come to do these things with.
All of that reinforces the delusion.
It's,
it's very similar to,
to,
uh,
to religions.
The way that religions focus with the
difference being that people in
religions,
people who have faith,
they think they're a bit better people
as a consequence of them having faith.
Whereas very few people in the
delusional martial arts,
you think that they think they're good
fighters.
But,
oh,
the techniques are too dangerous to task
or we,
you know,
we can't,
we can't do this and see if we did this,
we would kill you.
Uh,
but those cultures of delusion keep
people trapped in thinking about things
that remove them from reality.
Yeah,
there's definitely some of that,
but I think there's some good to the
idea of respecting a Dojo as a place
where you,
when you walk into it.
One of the things stupid,
but it's true.
When I was a kid,
I used to have keys to uh,
the,
it was a doe Jang,
cause it was taekwondo is the Korean
word doubled.
I,
even when no one was there,
I would bow when I would walk in,
when I would go to work out in the
middle of the night,
like I would go there,
I had keys.
So I,
I would,
I would train sometimes I'd show up at
midnight,
I go there and lock the door and go in
myself.
And then,
but when stepped into the training area,
I would always bow and I was like almost
like an ocd thing.
Like,
I wouldn't not do it because I,
in my mind when I,
like I had been trained and taught that
when I entered that room I had to bow
and even with there's fucking no one
there man.
I'm by myself and I always bout like one
time my girlfriend,
my girlfriend was a freak in high
school.
She wanted to fuck in the,
in the gym and I was like,
we can't,
can't do it.
I'm like,
I won't do it.
We can't do it here.
And she's like,
come on.
I'm like,
nope,
not happening.
It was a lost opportunity for you?
Not really.
I fucked the shit out of her.
I fucked her all the time.
We were like little fucking rabbits,
but,
but it was,
there was the one place where I wouldn't
do it.
I was like,
we can't,
I can't do it here.
Like this is,
this is a sacred ground for me.
So I guess here's my problem with that,
besides the lost opportunity,
but it wasn't a lost opportunity for me.
It was an execution of discipline of my
mind.
Like I,
it was very hard for a 17 year old boy
to not have sex with this hot,
I think she was 1616 year old girl who
wanted a bang in this karate or
taekwondo gym.
That's like,
for me it was like that.
This,
this what,
what martial arts meant to me at the
time was there was this the first thing
that I had ever done that made me feel
like I wasn't a loser.
So my whole life I'd been insecure and
we had moved around a lot when I was a
kid.
I didn't really have a whole lot of
friends and I never felt like I fit in
and I always felt,
you know,
I didn't know my dad and you know,
my stepdad was a little distant.
There was all this stuff going on,
right?
There was all these things that just
didn't feel right,
didn't,
didn't make me feel good.
And then this one thing came along that
made me feel good.
It's one thing came along that I had
gotten really proficient,
not really quickly and was absolutely
obsessed with and I was doing it all
day,
all day.
And there was a,
that was my whole focus of my life.
Other than the girl.
No,
no,
it wasn't not sure.
I'm sure it wasn't good at that.
I'm sure it was probably terrible,
but point being like I wasn't willing to
sacrifice that.
Like the ideals.
It's interesting isn't it?
Yeah.
So we use the same today.
Do you think,
I mean do you have that notion of sacred
with regard to these things?
I don't have that notion of sacred when
it comes to like a space,
but I do in terms of like my approach to
things.
Like what if I,
if I'm focused on something,
like I don't allow myself to get
distracted.
If something is is,
is,
is critical,
something's like really important to
focus on.
And I decided this is what I'm doing
now,
now I'm doing this,
you know?
So if I may wanna be overly personal,
but like your marriage,
you decided to do it,
you're focusing on it too.
So it's taken me,
marriage is a contract.
Okay.
Relationships?
Yes.
Like the way you engage with someone.
Like if you care about someone,
here's a good way.
Not just relationships as far as like
sexual relationships,
but friendships.
If you care about someone and you,
you really enjoy being with them and
they're one of the most important people
in your life.
Like when you interact with them,
I think you should interact with them
under that provision or with that
thought in mind with that.
Would that intention with what I missed?
You intention that you care about them
very deeply.
These are important people in your life
authentically.
Like you don't,
you don't ever want,
like I don't,
I would never like,
like really good friends.
I would never yell at them and um,
you know,
call them a piece of shit.
I never want you in my life.
Or it's like say crazy things to people
that sometimes people say hurtful
things.
Yeah.
You know,
it doesn't mean don't be critical.
It doesn't mean don't correct someone if
you see them doing something that you've
seen your friends doing something
stupid,
but that,
I don't think that's a good example.
I think,
um,
because marriage is not something that
like,
it's like something you're trying to do.
You know,
marriage is like,
or even relationships,
friendships are just their,
those are their interactions.
So they should ships or it's different.
Like it should be fun and enjoyable and
all that good stuff,
but I'm talking about as a discipline.
Yeah.
Well,
what I was trying to tease out from you
is that when you were 17,
you had this idea of the Dojo being a
sacred place.
Yeah.
And you talked about what that meant to
you and I'm curious if there's anything
that you hold sacred now.
Um,
that's a good question.
Like that.
Not,
no,
I've definitely changed my ideas about
what that even was at the time.
I think what that was that need for that
sacred space in this like intense
concentration and purity of that
environment was really like my,
my ticket out,
my ticket out of this life that was
really unfulfilling to manhood.
Yeah.
That definitely to sovereignty,
personal sovereignty,
to,
um,
to realize that,
it's not that I,
it's not that I was a loser.
He says that I wasn't a winner and I had
to figure out how to be one.
It wasn't,
it wasn't all my failures,
what I was is now and all those failures
and all those mistakes and bad feelings
that I had,
those were really just lessons and that
now that I have this new focus and this
new thing and it's shown massive
positive results,
I will honor that.
And that's what it was to me,
that the new focus being one martial
arts,
fighting,
competing taekwondo.
So that space to Dojo,
that Doe Jang represented a sacred place
for me because it represented this new
ticket and I wasn't about to cash that
in for some Pussy Holla.
You know what I'm saying?
Like was my thoughts Matt.
Now my,
um,
I mean if there's anything I would think
that the world like life itself is that
environment life itself,
is that,
that Doh Jang life itself is that thing.
So you don't ever want,
you don't want to steal,
you don't want to commit crimes against
people.
You don't want to do things to hurt.
All those,
those,
those terrible things that we see out in
the world.
If the world was your Dough Jang,
if the world was your,
your church,
if the world was your sacred place,
you would never want to commit bad acts
in your sacred place.
That's a lovely,
I wish we could figure out a way to,
to help people adopt those values.
You know,
I wish we could come up with some way
to,
especially when we see what's going on
in the Middle East and we see what's
going on in the world and we see what
the way we're treating our environment
or climate,
I wish there was some way to make that
real and palatable to people so that we
would start being more authentic and
more sincere with someone.
And,
and I think what you said about,
it's not about criticism,
the way I look at it,
I think it's about forthright speech.
You can be forthright in your speech
with somebody and not be,
be be an asshole,
not be a jerk.
I think those kinds of relationships
for,
for me,
aristotle talks about that too.
But for me,
I think that the most meaningful
relationships are those people with whom
I can be authentic.
And be myself and be real.
And those are kind of,
I don't like the word sacred though.
It's,
I guess that's the one kind of nitpick I
have.
Cause you attach that to religion.
Well because I attach it to the
inability to revise something.
I attach it to the utmost respect.
Yeah.
So if we replaced a sacred for respect,
I think we'd be noises.
It's one of the things I don't like
about labels.
Like I like intent and intent.
Like my,
my idea of sacred is not like God.
Like it's not like a sum,
it's not a deity,
this unnamed unknown word that's been
passed down from person to person.
It's based on personal experience based
on a real thing.
So when I say sacred,
like my law,
my love for my children is sacred.
Right.
You know,
like I say it in that window.
I don't,
you know,
say it like in terms of like harps and
the clouds and all that kind of jazz.
And when we were talking about,
um,
like don't be an asshole to people you
care about.
Like it doesn't mean it certainly
doesn't mean I'm some sort of a perfect
person.
Certain doesn't mean that I have been an
asshole.
And then sometimes when you're
responding to someone else being
retarded or someone being ridiculous,
you can be an asshole because you don't
have the patience for it anymore because
you don't have the a at the moment you
don't have the temperament to charity.
Yeah.
What?
Yeah,
it could be maturity.
It could be you're overwhelmed.
There's a lot of variables.
So like if someone hears this and says,
you know all,
well man,
I've been an asshole lately.
Maybe I'm a bad person.
Like No.
It's just recognizing those moments
where he probably could have handled
something better and continuing to
approve and then also this idea,
here's this is a really important
one because people have this idea that
somehow I'm 30 years old,
I shouldn't be doing this anymore.
I'm 50 years old.
I should have learned by now.
That's all bullshit.
Throw that away,
tossed that shit aside.
You like these ideas of numbers that
people have in their head that by a
certain age you should stop.
You are alive and if you are alive and
if you are thinking all those numbers
that you keep attaching,
will,
you know when Einstein was 30 heat or
shut the fuck up,
stop doing that.
That that is a waste of your time and
stop saying to yourself,
I should be better by now.
I'm such a total non helping thought
what you need to think of his life.
You're living,
you're alive right now.
And if you've made a mistake and you're
still continuing to learn and grow,
that's all just data.
And I think bundled with that is
gratitude.
Gratitude is giant.
We don't say a prayer in my household,
but we go around every night.
We have seven people living with us and
we say what we're grateful for and what
you went into commune when you doing?
Uh,
we have,
it's a lot.
We have a,
it's a long story of a woman from China
there.
It's a lot of Christ.
But what does she do?
Wink,
wink.
No sex slaves and bocce though.
We have another woman who lives in the
cargo container.
Everybody who lives in the garage over
there,
no attention to the banging.
Um,
no,
but you know,
we go around,
we talk about what they're grateful for.
Everyone is grateful and I think that
there's something,
it's,
it's an opportunity to be authentic at
that time.
But it's also like,
I think verbalizing those things are
important.
So it's not just the negative,
I shouldn't be doing this,
but just the positive look.
Is it general as a general rule of
thumb,
if you ever have any doubts about it,
just be kind to people.
It also,
it's a,
it's great when you reinforce it with
your friends,
like verbalizing it like a,
um,
I'm a big fan of tell.
I tell my friends I love them all the
time.
Like me and my friend,
like my wife jokes around about it.
She goes,
I don't know any men that tell their
friends.
They love him all the time.
But all my friends do,
we all tell each other we love each
other.
You know,
I love you brother.
And we hang up the phone.
I'm dealing with all my friends and you
know,
there were always hugging and always
saying,
I appreciate you.
You know,
I think it's really important.
I have a very tight knit group of
friends that I care about very much,
and they're all very,
they're very motivated and they're
healthy and the,
you know,
they're not without flaws,
but they're there.
They got shit going on and it empowers
me yet new up.
So here's why.
Here's why that's important.
Because you got the tattoos,
you got to build,
you've been in the ring,
you're friends with whomever,
whoever you're friends with.
And I think that whether you like it or
not,
you're in a position,
particularly with young people to look
up to you.
And that is exactly the kind of behavior
that we want to see modeled.
It's not emotionally immature for a guy
to cry at a tragic event.
It's,
I tell my friends I love them.
I tell you know,
people,
I tell my buddy over there,
I'm incredibly grateful for the
opportunity to stay his house,
et cetera.
And I think that
that kind of,
we live in a culture that's suppressed,
these particularly males,
this the ability for men to communicate
in an authentic way.
Also to experience emotion.
Like this idea of somehow or another
being stoic has virtue to it,
especially in the form,
in face of tragedy or even joy.
Like I sometimes cry more or for happy
moments sometimes and I do for a sad
moments,
but I,
I'll cry,
I'll cry fucking cartoons man.
I almost cried.
I have not a ton of times,
I'm not crying to cartoons.
But yeah.
It's interesting.
I think that that journey from you as a
17 year old to now,
I mean there was some really core
lessons for people out there struggling
with maybe issues of sexuality or issues
of feeling they hate the world and then
on good enough or their,
they,
their self esteem issues are they,
and I think that they,
yeah,
it acceptance and that's what we all
want.
We all want to be loved and look.
So I'm,
I'm 49 and it's like I'd much rather be
people say about me,
hey,
you know,
pizza really good guy.
Then pizza,
really smart guy.
I want,
I want to,
uh,
you know,
I want to embody those virtues.
But,
but more than that,
I think that um,
the story that you told there,
it's,
it's something that's accessible to
people and it's a type of thing that we
need to do.
We need to figure out how to move our
culture towards these more humane ways
of dealing with people.
And my own opinion is that we don't need
superstitions to do that.
You're a perfect example of that,
right?
We don't need people making objective
claims about reincarnating and times
through bodies like the dilemma or wait
a minute,
you don't think the Dalai Lama is a
reincarnated saying,
are you serious?
You got,
you got nervous there for a moment.
I thought,
wow,
this is going to be a long conversation.
You see my Buddha said another buddha
right there.
See that's the funny thing.
If like I'll call it just call bullshit
on that in class and everybody will
freak out.
Whereas if I say,
Jesus walking on water and I do,
you can join.
But if you start taking a moment,
Buddhists and people were like,
Whoa,
bullshit.
You know,
how could you say that?
Whatever.
The Dalai Lama is so cool.
He's friends with Steven Seagal.
Yeah.
Well you actually saw them years ago
together doing their little thing.
That all gets connected.
Yeah.
No,
I um,
I had a psychedelic trip that or saw a
bunch of Golden Buddhas.
So that's what lsd about no DMT.
Oh Wow.
Cause that cause that like literally
that guy like in that position,
but there was fractals with millions of
them,
infinite numbers of them.
It was very strange.
Um,
so that's what that,
that little puts,
this guy made it for me.
I wish I remembered this homeboy's name.
I'll find it somewhere and I'll throw it
up on instagram.
I think it's on my instagram picture.
Right.
I don't know.
I'll find it.
But um,
yeah,
all of those things,
all those things are not necessary.
It's a,
I think we are necessary like all these,
uh,
the,
the false beliefs and all the things,
what they are is like scaffolding.
I feel like they're scaffolding for like
evolution and I think that that's
ultimately the benefit that religion
does provide is in,
in these insane beliefs in the sky,
gods and all these different things and
we show reverence to these,
uh,
these deities and they have these rules
that we must follow.
Otherwise we would be punished in those
rules.
There becomes order and then the order
becomes society.
And that's,
that's something that people always like
to fall back on.
Like we are a Judeo Christian sound
founded society and our Judeo Christian
ethics.
Like I saw some woman who was arguing
about Muslim terrorists and that was
like one of the big things that this is
this,
this country was founded on Judeo
Christian ethics.
Sowhat monkeys were founded on eating
bananas and we're not monkeys anymore.
No.
It's like it's such a stupid fucking
like just because something's founded on
something that's illogical,
it doesn't mean you should have
reverence for that illogical things
perfectly stated.
That's part of the problem I think with
once we make ideas sacred.
Yes.
And they become much more difficult,
if not impossible to revise like George
Bush saying,
which is actually I invite your viewers
or listeners to listen to this.
Uh,
he's prayed about the war in Iraq.
He knows who God wants them to do.
So the moment you do that,
it becomes irreversible.
I used to have a bit about that where
George Bush was like,
you know,
uh,
that he's prayed about the world in a
rack and you know,
God blessed the troops.
Imagine if he said instead of that we
have found Satan,
he is in Afghanistan and we're moving
tanks into that area.
Everybody would be like,
Whoa,
what the fuck did you do?
Say?
Right.
That's the,
that's the draw.
That's the line that we draw.
Like you're not hitting out.
He said he prayed to vishnu or
something.
Nope.
I mean,
you're not allowed to say that.
You know the devil.
You're not allowed to say the devil is
real.
Like,
and you never hear the president bring
up the devil.
They'll bring up God.
God blessed the troops.
Got,
they'll never say Satan is at work and
Satan is in the hearts and minds of
these,
uh,
these enemies.
They never say that because it's so
preposterous that we're slowly as
evolution as thinking evolves and
changes.
I know evolutions where I'm worried for
there,
but as it improves and expands,
we are no longer accepting the idea of
Satan.
Like culturally,
culturally,
Satan was an accepted thing hundreds of
years ago.
It was parallel like he,
like if you looked at the mentions of
Satan and dimensions of God,
they were right up there together.
You're blaming Satan on the bad things
and you praising God for the good
things.
That's no longer the case.
Now we just cling to these absurd
notions of this one that's watching us
all the time.
And you've got to sort of peripherally
mention it and casually reference it
without going into detail.
And you're allowed to do that because it
makes people think,
well,
you're on the same page as me.
You're a god feeling Kurt and Christian
man like myself,
I'm a god fearing Christian man myself
as well.
God bless you.
God bless you as well.
You know,
but if you go out,
Satan is looking out for you.
Peyton's watching you right now,
Satan is just letting the air out of
your tires.
Like you go,
oh,
that guy's a fucking idiot.
You know,
like we've moved past Satan.
Yeah.
But we haven't moved past Scott.
Exactly right.
Or the idea of God,
even though,
I mean if there is some all knowing
entity that is controlling everything
and is filled with love and has a grand
plan for the universe,
they have yet to show themselves.
So this is all just a concept and an
idea with no basis.
In fact.
And as we have found more facts about
the nature of reality in the world
itself,
it seems more and more preposterous with
every day,
every day the scientists come up with
these new equations that show the the
way the universe could have possibly be
been formed.
And the every day that these fucking
guys at the cern laboratory,
the,
they're the large Hadron collider,
are discovering these what were at one
time theoretical particles showing them
to be true in their calculations to be
correct.
We're having.
We have a deeper and deeper
understanding of the universe,
but we think now,
we love to think that right now that
were filled with knowledge and we'd love
to look at ourselves now and look at the
past as well.
They didn't know back then,
but we know now,
but if we looked in the past,
they would have the same ideas.
They would look back at those poor
monkey people with the bananas and then
they'll go those fucking dummies.
They didn't even know houses yet.
We will one day look back at 2015 like
what a bunch of fools,
what a bunch of ridiculous people that
were still,
they have this incredibly complicated
society in this wonderful access to
information,
but yet they were still shackled down by
ideology and killing each other over
religion and ancient superstitions that
the dictated their behaviors.
Like what a weird time to be in.
They'll look at,
they'll look at us now in 2015 they'll
say,
what a strange time this is adolescent
period of,
of,
of enlightenment,
where they're just still there,
still concentrating on stupid shit in
the fucking president of the United
States can openly talk about God and
every and no and no one goes,
what is God?
What are you saying?
Like what are you saying?
Do you think Jesus came back from the
dead weight?
What do you think?
Do you think someone walked on water?
Do you believe in the literal
translation?
Are you an old testament guy or a new
testament guy?
Well off a new instruments?
He's like,
no.
Well the New Testament was made by
Constantine who was a fucking Roman
emperor who wasn't even Christian.
He didn't even believe it.
He was,
he was,
he became a Christian.
I was fucking death bed.
Like that's when he became a Christian.
I go,
these people that are really into the
new testament and like,
I'll
talk about old testament shit and people
get mad at me on twitter.
They'll send me this fucking hate texts.
You understand?
Motherfucker.
What the difference is the Old
Testament,
the new testament,
because the new testament is utter horse
shit.
It was created by a bishop and a fucking
emperor.
That's a fact.
That's like established religious fact
like everyone knows where it came from.
And not only that,
it was written hundreds of years after
the death of Jesus.
So what are you talking about?
Because if you're talking about the old
stuff,
you got to go deep.
What would go to the Dead Sea Scrolls?
Go,
go to the,
go to the fucking did go to the most
ridiculous aspects of that and tell me
you basing your life on that because
that's even more preposterous.
They found them in clay pots in Qumran,
written on animal skins.
These people thought the world was flat
and a son was 17 miles away and we're
going to have,
they did.
They really did.
And we're going to,
we're going to do,
this is what we're going to live our
lives.
This is it.
This is all the facts we need.
Fucked the whole large Hadron collider.
Fuck cern.
You know,
Fuck Steven Hopkins and fuck quantum
physics.
Fuck Neil degrasse Tyson.
Fuck those dudes with their telescopes.
Now that we're going to base it on
leather skins and and and,
and charcoal ink,
right?
Like really that's,
that's the,
that's the conversation we're having
when we're talking about ideological
religions.
That was a thing of beauty by the way.
Oh thanks.
That was a thing of beauty,
what it is and people think,
well you renew fuse your nurse school,
your,
what do you believe in?
I had a guy yell at me at a comedy club
once cause I did this bit about
scientology.
I do this bit about scientology,
about watching a scientology documentary
with my mom who made me go to Catholic
school and how my mom thinks
scientology's religion.
Ridiculous.
I'm like,
what the fuck is this guy like,
Yo,
what do you believe in?
What do you believe in?
Like what if I have to believe in
something?
Right.
Do I have to believe I believe in
everything that has been proven.
I believe that this is made out of wood
and I see it when I'm proven wrong.
Right.
When change your mind,
it's back to the Jujitsu thing again.
But when you also think about it,
what an unbelievable arrogance to think
that you know the will of the creator of
the universe.
You know what he wants you to do.
You know where he wants you to put your
genitals.
I mean,
like you said it philosophy,
it's called the problem of induction or
looking at the past,
the past,
past,
resembling the past.
And we will look back,
there's absolutely no question in my
mind that you're correct and we will
say,
wow,
will you believe this?
This was,
how could we possibly have believed
this?
But what's interesting to me is we know
that that will happen.
Like we know that that will happen and
it's an opportunity for us to reflect
and say,
wow,
are we being arrogant right now?
W are we thinking we know things?
So we pretending to know things when we
don't know them.
And I think,
I think that a lot of that God talk is a
type of arrogance.
I think it's a type of people,
I dunno,
wanting to assert how moral they are so
they reap advantages.
The president or,
I mean,
I think it's a very complicated social
and even political problem,
but it's also a type of arrogance.
It is definitely a type of arrogance and
it's also a way that people stab the
moral high ground.
They establish a dominant social
position over you.
And the people love to do that.
They'd love to do that with their pious
attitude.
What they're doing is by,
by them accepting these religious
tenants,
they are somehow are superior to you.
And some people don't do that.
And you know,
I shared a hunting camp with this guy.
I don't need to names names.
A wonderful guy who was a,
an elk hunter and this guy would get up
in the morning every day before
everybody.
And we've got up fucking early,
you know,
we would leave the camp by 6:00 AM so
this guy was up,
I would get up to take a shower like
5:00 AM and this dude was up reading the
Bible and he never talked about it and
he never talked about like God or Jesus
or any of the rules.
But to him it was a way that he explored
these ideas and how he related to the
world and in application.
This guy was a fantastic,
absolutely.
He was a wonderful guy.
Like he was,
he was kind and it was like when you had
conversations with him,
he was generous and it was very friendly
and he was curious and he would ask like
these really introspective questions,
like he was a good guy.
And I think that's what matters.
I think it matters less whether or not
someone is an atheist or not or a Hindu.
And I think what matters is how we treat
other people.
I think what manages,
if we're kind to people,
if we listen to people,
if we do our best to engage them
honestly and authentically and often we
get too caught up in,
well,
what is someone's real,
especially now with the Republicans
going bizarre,
bizarre fuck with this whole Islam
thing.
It's just crazy and disgraceful.
Well,
you know,
did you see that video is a fantastic
video that's just been put out recently
I think by some guys in Holland.
Um,
where they were because it's in another
language.
Oh,
the Bible.
Yeah.
I saw that.
They put a cover of the,
put the Koran cover on the Bible and
then read passages to people on the
street and they asked him what do they
think about this?
And you know,
they were like,
wow,
this is ridiculous and this is
outrageous.
And it was all from the Bible,
like Hilarious,
hilarious shit that a lot of people
don't know is in the Bible.
And when you even bring this up,
people already,
you're questioning their beliefs.
So they start foaming at the mouth and
fuming and that,
fuck,
I can feel my phone get heavy from hate
tweets right now.
It's just coming in.
You're fucking question in my view of
reality and it makes me uncomfortable
when not going to work.
Right.
But isn't that the exact same issue with
someone doing a fantasy based martial
arts?
Oh a hundred percent I've had
conversations with people where they are
fucking furious at me because I don't
believe in their death touch.
I've had conversations with people they
like,
you know,
you are arrogant and your belief and
martial arts and you're in a position of
a,
of influence because of your work for
the UFC and what you're doing is you're,
you're fucking up.
Cause you're not telling the truth
about certain stop.
Right?
Like did you stop abandoned it,
but,
but you,
we,
if you're like me,
who,
like I said,
I was martial arts and that the doe Jang
was so sacred to me,
I wouldn't need to have sex with my
girlfriend there.
That represents like such an important
part of their life.
It's just so lucky for me that it
happened during my formative period
where I was exposed to reality at a
young age where I had to accept it.
I was like,
God,
Jesus,
you know,
I had to accept that these techniques
don't really work all the time.
Some of them work,
but you have to learn all the other
stuff for them to work at all.
Yeah.
And I wonder about,
again,
so few people have written about this.
I wonder about the experience that you
had of that.
And I had of that we were in the same
boat realizing over time that these
things just didn't work and we had
wasted our time.
And I wonder how similar that is to
someone's escaped from a faith,
you know,
like 100% people that have escaped from
cults.
Like I've had folks on that have a,
used to be in cults.
Kurt Metzger is a perfect example,
is a hilarious standup comedian friend
of mine and you know,
he was in Jehovah's Witness.
Is that what it yeah,
I think so.
And um,
he uh,
you know,
he won't accept any stupid shit now
cause he's like,
and he's like,
no,
like when it comes to the regressive
left and some of these ideologies where
you have to look at something in a
certain way and you can't look at it in
another way,
it's like a dogma and he's like,
no,
no.
I've seen this before.
I know what this is.
What you're doing is you're,
you're saying you have to think a
certain way.
That's bullshit.
Like it can be discussed like you q can
discuss certain aspects of people's
behavior or gender identity or gender
pronouns are in fact,
not only can it be discussed,
but it has to be discussion.
We have to have arenas and a lot of
people have been writing about this
lately.
I wrote about in my book and I tweeted
about it.
If we have,
if we're not allowed an opportunity to
have a conversation than extremists will
step in with the answers.
Like trump is a great example.
So we have to create spaces,
talk about spaces.
This is probably another offshoot of the
conversation space.
The regressive left,
right?
We need to create opportunities for
people to,
for sincere inquirers to engage things.
And right now we don't have that.
And again,
I,
I can bring it back to Jujitsu.
I mean you could just think about what
would happen if you know,
this is a technique,
you do this,
blah,
blah.
It's sacred.
We don't question it.
Then you'd never get to the truth.
You deny people the opportunities that
they need to figure out things for
themselves.
100%,
a hundred percent.
And I think martial arts is an excellent
vehicle for that.
The one of the things that was explained
to me when I was really young,
they're really did sink in.
My,
uh,
instructor,
was a,
uh,
a disciple of general chase,
young [inaudible] who was the founder of
taekwondo.
He was,
you know,
he taught it to troops and he was like,
or the,
the guy's like really honed the
techniques for maximum power and
efficiency and leverage.
And He,
um,
they had this idea that martial arts was
a vehicle for developing human
potential.
And,
uh,
I read that when I was like 15,
and I've always used that phrase because
I think that's a,
uh,
such a massive,
yeah.
What do you mean by such a massive what,
uh,
well,
it's,
it's so clear when you,
when you understand that we will,
you go through life.
Life is filled with questions,
a diversity puzzles,
different things.
You have to figure out the questions you
have to ask of yourself.
Examining your own behavior,
objective reasoning.
There's all these different variables
that come into play when it comes to
life.
And I think those are highlighted in the
realm of martial arts because mark,
if you can land a kick and you knock
someone out and then that that happened,
that worked and you were in the
ultimate,
like especially the ultimate fighting
championship is a perfect example of
that.
But there's,
there's no higher level of problem
solving than problem solving with dire
physical consequences because your
emotions are on the line,
your fears,
your anxiety.
There's so,
there's so many fight or flight
mechanisms in place,
there's self doubt,
there's,
you know,
how much discipline did you truly
execute in training?
Did you give everything you had?
Did you reach your full potential?
Most people go through life without even
coming close to their full potential.
And they live life in this,
this weird fog of uncertainty and of
regret and of,
of,
of just this feeling that they're not
accomplishing what they want to,
that they're not achieving their full
potential.
And that martial arts is a vehicle for
developing potential because through the
very difficult training and through
pushing yourself when you don't think
you can,
and through this overwhelming desire for
comfort,
we don't want to get out of bed.
What are you,
you don't want to do the training where
you would rather just blow it off and
don't go to class.
By forcing yourself to do that it,
it engages the muscles of discipline.
The inner muscles.
Yeah.
And it also you understand about
accomplishing goals and about about
reality facing things that it's just so
important.
So again,
it's Jujitsu.
When you defeat somebody,
like if you,
you,
you work really hard and you tap someone
else,
you get a sense of,
you get a little,
I'll speak for myself.
I feel good.
Like wow,
like I worked for this,
I tried hard,
I work on my baseball back,
choke now and I feel pretty good.
So that activity,
your hard work brought you to a point in
which
you would tap somebody out.
And as a consequence of that,
you feel self esteem.
What we have done is we have inverted
the system.
We tried to teach self esteem absent any
accomplishments.
That's not the way it works.
Self esteem is a byproduct of hard work
of something that you have done as a
direct result of an accomplishment.
So every,
every few years they give Americans,
they give kids all around the world to
test.
I read this in um,
Martin is the conspiracy of ignorance
many years ago,
excuse me.
In the to the test is like,
Hey,
all these people in the world,
you know the Koreans,
the industrialized world,
Japanese,
German center,
they took this,
how do you think you did in relation to
them?
Americans consistently score on the
bottom core tile in terms of their math
and science,
how well they did and in comparatively,
but they score extraordinarily high.
Number one,
almost always in terms of self esteem.
We have taught the wrong things.
We focused on the wrong things.
Our school systems have been oriented
toward the wrong things.
And I think again,
you can just bring that back to Jujitsu
and look at it.
Look at that.
You don't,
you couldn't possibly,
you could teach someone all of a self.
So you walk in,
they get a white belt,
you teach him to feel good about
themselves,
do this to this,
to this,
but does it work?
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's,
you could get a lot of the lessons from
martial arts out of a lot of difficult
endeavors.
You know,
I just don't think you get the problem
solving aspect at the,
it's such a high level,
like some people find that in rock
climbing because it's scary.
And then in,
in,
in accomplishing that and then getting
through that you,
you,
you learn about yourself and learn about
your ability to Chicago adversity and to
face your fears.
But I just think that martial arts is a
more intense version of it because
there's all this connected to combat and
to this,
the physical challenge of overcoming
another human being.
And it's one of our biggest fears.
One of our biggest fears other than
falling off of a mountain is being
dominated by another human being,
getting your ass kicked and conflict
where we have this long history of war.
I mean,
I was talking to,
I heard that podcast the Jocko.
Yeah.
The seal guy.
That's a great podcast.
He's an awesome guy.
But we were talking about the
conversation that I had with my friend
Duncan trussell where I said that and
we,
it was kind of a revelation for the both
of us and like human history is a
history of the wars.
That's when we talk about human history.
It's like the stuff that happened in
between the wars and you know,
some inventions,
but it's mostly the wars.
That's most of the history,
you know,
where whether it's world war one or
world war two or Vietnam or you know,
there's all these different conflicts
that that happened and those are the
bulk of our history.
When we,
when we consider the errors in the past,
when we consider the,
the,
the ages of the different things that
happened,
we consider like kingus Khan and
Napoleon Alexander the Great and all
these different things that happen.
We're considering war.
Yeah.
I'll,
I'll go off on a little tangent if you
don't mind.
It makes me think,
I've been thinking about talking to my
buddy over there about life and the
universe in this thing called the Fermi
paradox.
Where is everybody and I wonder if that
the Fermi paradox being the amount of
life that must be out there.
You know,
like why haven't we been contacted yet?
I consider that to be just an
extraordinarily interesting question,
but I wonder if what you just said that
our history has been a history of war.
I,
I wonder if inherent in every species
that has evolved,
they've had a similar history of war,
you know,
because they've been subject to
different evolutionary mechanisms and
pressures and such,
you know,
like different atmospheres would have
it,
but I wonder if it's conflict over
resources,
conflict over,
you know,
whatever.
Maybe they have another gender or
something.
I wonder if that's just intrinsic in the
nature of life.
I think it is.
I think what's intrinsic in the nature
of life is that sort of problem solving
and that nature wants to find the best
method of achieving a goal.
And so the methods that are ineffective
die off.
And that's why 90% of the living species
that have been on this planet are
extinct.
They no longer exist because they
weren't effective enough to be,
to keep reproducing.
And you can say,
no,
we'll a lot of them because people wipe
them out.
People are evil and people are horrible.
People are the dominant species.
What species do,
I mean many animals have wiped out
animals.
You know,
there's a,
there's a real issue right now with wild
pigs and ground nesting birds because
wild pigs being an invasive species,
they're dealing with these birds that
nest on the ground that didn't have
these animals hunting them.
And,
or they shouldn't even say hunting.
They're eating their eggs.
Um,
so that's just an ineffective way to
diet.
Yeah.
They,
it's an ineffective way to take care of
your eggs.
Can't leave them on the ground and a
place where these fucking pigs are
rooting up everything and eating
everything in front of them.
So if they go ahead.
No,
it's okay.
No.
If they don't adapt,
then there'll be no more.
Yes,
absolutely.
Are Gone.
And you know,
people say,
Oh,
it's so evil.
It's so awful.
Would you want a world filled with only
the spotted owl?
No.
Okay.
Well,
the spotted owl dies off.
It's cause it sucked.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I'm not saying we should kill the
spotted owl,
but the motherfucker didn't make it.
Okay.
And the other animals are still here and
eagles are still here and got,
by the way,
you wouldn't want a world filled with
all eagles either.
And there's a competition between eagles
in salmon.
If the eagles eat all the salmon,
we're going to be pissed at the eagles,
you know?
I mean,
if the eagles make the stamp,
the salmon extinct,
we're going to be like,
what the Fuck Eagles.
But you know,
it's funny when you're,
so you're talking about this and uh,
in the back of my head,
I mean,
you're absolutely right.
In the back of my head I'm thinking,
wow,
like the,
so we're having a conversation,
right?
You and I are talking like if I started
as talk about that,
some of that stuff in class,
that's when you get the whole trigger
warnings,
safe spaces and stuff.
Again,
like people would freak out.
But look,
this is really important.
I mean,
you're talking about species,
you're talking about survival.
You're talking about taking care of the
planet and you know,
how do we weigh the concerns of the
spotted owl against the loggers?
I mean,
you're talking about some really
important things and the recourse to I'm
offended or I can't think of what makes
me upset.
It makes me think that maybe soon
universities won't be the,
I mean we'll have to have these
discussions out of the universities,
which really be,
it's a great for you in your show.
It's at,
but it's terrible for the society.
It's terrible for the university.
It's terrible.
The universities in a sense of cease to
have these sorts of conversations.
When you watch those children scream at
that professor at Yale and then you find
out that that guy was disciplined and
like,
why were they fired?
Or they stepped down.
They resign.
Yeah,
I think they resigned.
we're fucked.
But I think,
I think liberals are eating themselves.
I think the left is literally arrested,
left breast.
I think there's a difference.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
that's a good point.
Because liberals in terms of social
change and progress and you know,
acceptance of a various different
people.
I think that's wonderful.
It's great.
But I think that this regressive left
with this very rigid ideology of what
you can and can't say.
And the,
the behaviors which they,
they engage in enforcing these things.
I think it's preposterous.
And I think that ultimately what's going
to happen is you're not going to have
these kind of structures,
these,
these places where people go and you're
going to be learning things online.
It's going to be a lot worse before it
gets better.
And the hard thing is that many of your
listeners are not in academia.
And when we tell these stories,
people,
they think that this kind of just making
this too,
you are an academia.
So explain it from a first person
perspective.
Um,
so I give,
give you an example.
Okay.
So I had uh,
an individual and class and the
individual is not even part of the class
and they'll write in the syllabus.
I put in this entire class as a trigger
warning.
Like the whole thing a to z.
You had to write that.
I put it in.
They,
so if you're going to trigger warning
right in the syllabus,
the whole thing,
I love the fact that you even use
trigger warning trigger warning you so
fucking stupid.
I did the whole thing.
We'll see.
Here's what happens.
Cause I was actually just brought up in
charges again.
And if you don't do that then you know,
people can say,
well you didn't warn me.
Well actually I did.
I wondered the first day,
it's an Ita.
None of these in the syllabus.
I'll say this [inaudible] it's bold in
caps in the syllabus,
in increased font.
So everybody knows your class is a
trigger warning.
Yep,
Yep.
The whole thing,
the whole thing.
And you know,
when I,
I went to the dean or whatever and he's
questioning about things and I'm like,
and I said,
you know what?
Hey,
it's in the thing.
And he said,
well,
can you see how people could be offended
by this stuff?
And I'm like,
of course people are gonna be offended
by everything you mean fit her.
Bailey,
I talked with you talking about the
woman who's offended because darth vader
was black,
right on MSNBC.
The Dave Rubin
tweeted today,
right?
Which is one of the dumbest fucking
things I've ever seen in my life.
She's saying that star wars is racist
because darth vader's black.
Meanwhile,
darth vader is not black.
They took the mask off.
You'd dump con it's a white dial into
there.
So I'm an idiot.
I'm not going to say I can trump that,
but let me give you a couple examples.
Look,
skywalker's his son too.
And that's another white guy.
You fucking idiot.
So here's one.
So this woman is in the class and I give
a class at the end of the end of the
class,
she says,
I've never seen so many microaggressions
in,
I think it was nice to class,
uh,
knowledge,
values and rationality.
We use Sam Harris's book,
the moral landscape in that class.
And we talk about,
well,
we talk about heavy things.
You know,
we talked about Isis,
we talked about cultural relativism.
We talked about is there a way to make a
cross cultural,
I mean,
we're talking about things that frankly,
people in college should be talking
about,
right?
Because they vote their citizens in a
democracy and they need to engage these
issues.
And College professors are petrified.
They're just in,
in a sense,
I understand that because it's a theft
of one's time.
My case,
I don't care because I have no
opportunity.
I was told point blank that you'll never
get promoted.
You could publish 10 books from Harvard
and we won't promote you.
So once I found that out,
I said,
well,
I can talk about whatever I want,
so why did they tell you?
Well,
let me fit,
I'll finish.
So,
um,
so it was really interesting to me.
So she,
she gets up and she said,
I've never been so microaggressed the
guys,
you know,
racist.
This is someone that again was not even
the class,
there was not even in the,
in,
in the class.
And you know,
I,
I thought,
wow.
Like what my first,
it was like,
is this person totally insane or did I
say something that was really horrible?
What were the micro aggressions that she
was citing?
Oh,
well I focus in the racist part.
So I said,
well,
what did,
what did I say?
What did I say?
Because if I said something that was
racist,
I really do want to know cause I don't
want to be that kind of person.
So that's their belief revision thing
again.
Right,
right.
Okay.
So she said you used the example of star
trek in a class and you were shocked
when the woman,
when she,
she pointed the woman,
she didn't know she was right.
I was shocked.
I was genuinely,
I was almost flabbergasted that she
never heard of star Trek.
Like I understand not watching it,
but she never heard of it.
And then I used the example,
the example of Marilyn Manson,
right?
She said that you assumed that she
participated in white culture.
So that's racist.
Okay.
Now I,
so yeah,
so for Marilyn Manson is white culture.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this is a white guy.
So now we can really drill down in this
and think about this.
Can to find a forum,
black fans of Marilyn Manson,
I'm sure it's out there.
Go to read it out for forum.
So now we can really unpack this
insanity.
Okay.
So,
so she,
she tells people that everybody should
file a complaint against me.
And I said,
okay,
well you know,
well let's,
if you,
you look,
anybody is free to free to file
complaint.
Do you have the number?
I said,
would you like,
we'll put it around on the board and you
want to have a conversation with me?
She said,
no,
you're too far gone.
You're too far gone because you like
start or you mentioned star trek far.
Well,
I don't know.
See that's the thing.
It's like the horse analysis and run one
lane.
It runs off furiously in all directions.
And the whole thing is main thing that
people do though,
they say,
I can't discuss it with you.
You're too far gone.
That's a symptom.
That's a symptom of space.
Safe spaces,
trigger warnings and microaggressions in
your mind that goes in,
I cannot speak to you will not get
infected by your horrible ideas which
come from Satan.
You are too far gone or repent.
Repent.
Peter.
So,
so here's,
I mean,
this is what she's saying.
It is very,
it's very similar.
It's very similar on the left.
So what you're saying.
So here's what's happening.
So she black by the way,
cause it'd be awesome if she was white.
No,
she was his,
she was Hispanic.
Dammit.
So one of the things that that she was,
or maybe not,
I didn't know,
she said her name was [inaudible].
She rolled her eyes.
I don't remember what,
how dare you racist the in the first
name is Inigo Montoya.
The first thing I said to her is my
literally when she told me her name and
said,
I'm sorry if I can't pronounce it,
but he caught a mundo bond.
Okay.
So here's what's interesting about that.
So obviously she's been inculcated,
she is incapable and I never want to pay
pick on her because in a sense she's
just a victim,
right?
She's a victim of this malicious
ideology that's running across campuses
now.
But people like that are not capable of
engaging and entertaining ideas because
they have this,
the university protects them.
They can say they've been aggressed.
They can,
they can say they've been kind of
violated,
if you will,
like cognitively intellectually
violated.
But what's really interesting about
that?
Two things.
One,
she thinks that she can arbitrate
everybody else's reality.
So she thinks I can understand if I say
something and he's offended by it or I
say,
you know,
taekwondo and so like,
but she thinks that the regressive
thinks that they arbitrate people's
reality and they know what other people
should be offended by,
which is amazing.
But here's the really interesting part.
I Love Star Trek.
I'll show you my,
my daughter in a sec.
Offscreen,
I love Star Trek.
I'm the j clean.
No,
but she's Asian and know star Trek.
It has everything to do with paws.
It has,
it has everything.
That pause was the emphasis.
It has emphasis.
It has everything good because the
woman,
the woman I was shocked,
hadn't heard of star Trek was Asian.
You said she was?
No.
Who had heard of Star Trek?
It's a different woman now that there
were two women.
One was the woman who said she's never
been so offended in her whole life.
And the other one,
when she's,
when I missed,
she said she didn't hurt her,
hadn't heard of it because it was white
culture.
So,
okay.
Two different people.
So I haven't,
yeah,
I haven't articulated.
There's a woman in the class.
I use a structure for example.
She hasn't heard of it.
I'm stunned.
I'm like,
I can't believe
it.
And I use a Marilyn Manson example.
She hasn't heard of it.
I'm shocked.
Then the other woman,
the regressive,
the road,
the one who's watching.
Yeah,
the one who's watching the regressive
leftist says you're a racist.
You know something that better if I
don't remember exact words.
Okay.
Now I understand.
I was so confused.
I thought you were talking about the,
the,
all of these interactions.
I thought the woman who is the
regressive also hadn't heard about star
trek.
And that's,
that's a problem with mark circulation.
Not your understanding.
Just apologize.
So,
uh,
okay.
So w w what was really interesting to me
about that is that she identified that
person on the basis of her race,
not me.
She was assuming she made w when you're
a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
When you're a regressive leftist,
every single thing you think of as race,
gender,
oppression,
intersectionality,
which is parenthetically,
I have never heard their sectionality.
Anytime you,
you,
you see sectionality,
what does that,
anytime you hear someone use that word,
you can automatically assume they were
aggressive leftist and the next thing
out of your mouth they're most will be
some kind of smear campaign.
There's a hilarious video of Steven
crowder going up to people and asking
them what their preferred pronouns are.
I almost retweeted that,
but I thought,
you know what?
I got to get in trouble for right now.
I know that,
but that's what it is.
They have really infested the highest
levels of academia and it's funny,
these diversity offices,
they report directly to the president
like they,
they are offices in search of tasks,
but back to this example,
so she was the one who identified the
person on the basis of their race.
She identified me on the basis of their
race of your race because somehow
somehow there's,
there's a thing called white culture.
She knows what it is.
She's offended on someone else's behalf.
I'm a white CIS gendered heterosexual,
cisgendered use that term.
Uh,
okay.
Are you being forced to use that term?
Is that real?
Okay?
It's a question of being,
how's that work?
It's like,
is that a question of being forced to
use it?
But,
but,
but that's not a real term.
Like that's not in any dictionary or
bullshit nonsense.
But CIS gender is hilarious.
And the idea being that you shouldn't
have to say transgender because
transgender should be normal.
It's normal to want to be transgender.
It's like it's,
it's so normal that by saying
transgender,
you're making it abnormal.
So I should say sis gender for people
who aren't transgender.
Meaning if you are a male and you
identify as being a male,
you are a cis gendered metric.
You're fucking mail.
Like we're,
we're adding all,
here's the thing about look,
adding all this extra shit to define
things that are already defined by the
original word.
We don't need that.
You're doing it to prop up transgender.
Like that's the idea to make it so it's
even,
we'll put sis regular gender trans with,
right.
So now,
so,
okay,
if that was another
great explanation.
So now why do these people do this?
Well that's a long story,
but one value that's responsible for
that is radical egalitarianism.
Everything has to be radical.
Everybody has to be equal.
Yes.
Interesting though.
How,
you know,
and then they have these diversity
initiatives and diversity requirements.
We need more faculty of Color.
And I actually think that that's,
that can be a good thing in some
circumstances.
Uh,
so,
but what they mean is they mean
diversity and the most narrow,
bigoted kind of a way they mean it in
terms of skin color.
They don't mean it in terms of
ideological differences.
They're not enough.
They're hiring,
you know,
uh,
Republicans and Libertarians or
conservatives.
But the other thing that's interesting
is that,
you know,
I think it was,
it was a on Sam's podcast with Douglas
Murray.
He said,
we're going to be talking about pronouns
to the big thing.
Now we're going to be talking about
pronouns.
While these people are still sneaking
nukes in our cities.
It is a failure to Morley triage.
It is a,
it is a system wide failure.
That's,
that's trickled down to individuals
within the system to make it almost
impossible for them to make discerning
judgments about things.
And so we have this consequence now have
an entire generation of students who's
being trained not only to suspend moral
judgments,
but to think they're better people of as
being a result.
And it's also beautiful.
This is all coming from academia because
if you think about what a university as
an academia,
like a lot of people that are in
academia,
I went to college,
went on to Grad school,
got their masters or their phd,
started teaching,
never entered the real world,
stayed in a sheltered environment and
now they're dictating this sort of
behavior and thinking it's like,
it's like a Dojo in which they never,
it's everybody's training with everybody
else in the Dojo,
right?
I told you it's all mushy.
Like the whole thing can be seen through
that Lens.
And then that this radical ideology
coming in this area and wanting to
redefine reality.
Absolutely.
In this area,
they're not,
they're not going out into the real
world and experiencing the Congo and all
this crazy fucked up parts of the world
and understanding like you're dealing
with like an inherent problem with the
human race.
Like you can't redefine it by changing
pronouns and CIS gender.
It really is the most insidious form of
Cultural Myopia.
Like they think they have latched onto
some times they just making shit up.
They think they've latched onto some
universal truth about reality and now
they have this moral and I think that
the,
the moral underlying moral impulses that
they have a pretty good ones.
You know,
you don't treat people differently on
the basis of their licensing or you'd be
basically a cool person.
You will be asked.
Yes.
I think that those are there being a
laudable and forcing it.
They're not enforcing it with kindness
and compassion and understanding and
trying to promote this like positive
thing.
Now they're shaming and docs.
So that's the other piece that we need
to understand here.
The other piece is
the tactics and the techniques and these
people have really done a number on me
or they have attempted to they,
they mistake me for someone who gives a
shit.
I really don't care.
But the other thing is these people are
just the most mean spirited,
nasty,
vituperative operative.
Tam,
you ever heard that one?
No.
It goes to the google that Google that
vet to v VI.
Tiv Vituperative.
It means like,
you know a nasty name calling son of a
bitch.
I'm going to call someone that one day.
Wow.
The two operative like it.
There you go.
Bitter of your day.
Oh,
like it.
That's a good abusive or Tuper to fuck
you can.
These people are also characterized by
the strategies they use with when they
are engaging people.
The smear tactics,
if you say anything,
if you question or you challenge your
racist,
you're a bigot,
you're a homophobe.
But what that does is that shuts down
the conversation.
That's the end of the conversation.
So they have marginally,
it's,
it really is that not only are they
marginalize you,
it's this rise of the victim culture,
like every like victims or esteem.
Now I think I can find parallels when I
was talking about again with mixed with
martial arts is that like the Dojo to me
was sacred because this was something
that was transforming me and changing me
from a loser to someone who had like a
possible outcome that was positive that
I had potential.
I don't want a path out.
I think a lot of these people,
they come from environments where maybe
their parents were fucked up or racist
or dumb or they didn't like their life
or they've been raped or some kind of
physical trauma.
Yes,
that's a good point.
Um,
had horrible experiences with bad people
or you know,
and you know,
maybe abused in highschool,
bullied,
fucked with,
and now they found some culture where
they're being not just accepted,
but the,
the,
it's,
it's invigorating to them like other,
and then we're going to change this
world and we're going to make things
awesome for people and we're gonna,
you know,
we're going to make you ask people what
their preferred gender pronouns are.
This is so important.
We really need to get on right.
And they're there.
They're living in this environment.
And again,
you're dealing with a really young
people like,
like I was when I was young and I was
looking at this,
this stage of my life is this
transformative journey that I was on and
I was wholeheartedly dedicated to it.
Maybe that's what they're doing.
You know,
this is their transformative journey.
Yeah.
I think that's right.
And I wasn't going on others.
Yeah,
they're imposing it there.
They're using the mechanisms of the
university to impose those things.
I think that's right.
But the very things that we need reason
and rationality or liberatory,
they can liberate us.
They can emancipate us.
You know,
again,
Jujitsu is like that.
You can test ideas,
you can,
you know,
it's like,
it's a son of a bitch to have a guy had
a guy on
me,
he's like 300 pounds and he's like knee
ride me and then skull riding me.
I mean,
it's just not a very pleasant
experience.
Those both sound very gay and be riding
a skull riding.
That's a microaggression is a
micrograph.
So I wanted to get back to that,
that protest,
because I don't think we completely
finished it.
I was going to finish the thought that
it was,
give me the protest.
W This woman that was saying all this
stuff about you that you know you're
racist and that you're like,
yeah,
okay.
So you know,
I used the word hurtful before.
So one of the reasons that's really
hurtful to me is because my daughter's
Asian,
right.
And now as the age of twitter,
and that's like saying I'm not racist.
I have black friends.
No,
no,
no.
It's different getting,
I know you're kidding,
but,
but just think about,
just think about it for a second.
You know,
like my daughter grows up and this
person in my class at,
Oh,
you know,
he's like hates Asians or whatever,
Asians,
I just like to guy like star Trek,
right?
So,
so you know,
those things tend to have a life of
their own and then it's like,
oh,
but Goshen,
he's the guy who hates Asians,
right?
He's the guy.
Whereas,
no,
I'm just the guy who,
and this is the earlier point,
I was going to make the very thing that
these regressives one of the things that
they don't understand,
uh,
perhaps the most important is that
reason is liberatory w we can emancipate
ourselves through reason and
rationality,
but the only way to do that,
the weight,
that reason acts as a lubricant is in
social discourse.
Like we need to be able to have
conversations.
It's non negotiable.
Free speech is not a negotiation 100%.
It is pure.
And so these people,
they want to disinvite people if they
don't agree with them as opposed to
having,
you know,
uh,
an alternative speaker for their point
of view or debate.
I'm not a fan of debates but you know,
or debate.
But what they want to do is they want to
shut down the discourse,
but let's take that at a deeper level
and take a look at that.
Part of the problem with that is,
is that I firmly believe,
and I think I have evidence for this,
overwhelming evidence actually is a
pedigree and long pedigree in western
intellectual thought.
We can derive our values,
we can sit down and I can talk to you
and we can figure out and looking at the
black statue there,
Hendrix there,
we can figure out why we shouldn't
discriminate against people in the basis
of their skin color.
But the only way that we can do that,
it's not matte,
it doesn't come from a want,
is,
is that you need to be able to ask
questions,
right?
So we can figure things out in
discourse,
in dialog.
That's how we figure things out.
And these people want to shut down
discourse.
But if they do that,
then they become their own enemies.
They're the worst type of idealog
because they have beliefs,
but they haven't derived those beliefs.
So then those beliefs are then sacred,
right?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And the only way they're,
they're taking away the one thing that
we need to figure to figure stuff out.
It's like they're in Jujitsu.
They're taking away the resisting
opponent.
In this case,
they're taking away the dialectic,
the dialogue,
free speech,
open inquiry,
the ability to say things on campuses
without being smeared as a racist or a
homophobe or a bigot.
You're 100% right.
You couldn't be more right about that
aspect of this whole dilemma that they
are trying to stop the debate because I
think part of them knows what they're
doing is ridiculous.
Just like the the Ci Gong master that
wants to shoot you across the room when
there's a question,
they kind of know they've got to know
the question.
Right.
So that is what I've really been
thinking about.
Do they know that their ideologies are
bankrupt?
Do they know?
I mean,
and,
and again,
I'm thinking about guys at the top,
like Reza,
Aslan,
green.
Glenn,
Glenn Greenwald,
Jank from the young Turks.
Like when you have to make shit up and
lie,
it makes me think that you're not
genuine about your beliefs,
that you're not authentic.
Like I would just mention to someone the
other day,
I have no problem talking to someone who
tells me with total sincerity,
hey,
you know what?
I believe that there was a talking
snake.
Like I can have a conversation with that
guy.
He's sincere,
that Whoa,
that person's sincere.
They're,
you know,
they say this is what I believe,
but the regressives you can't,
it's almost impart the one thing you
need.
You can't have a conversation.
Cause if you ask a question,
you're,
you're smeared you,
you become a whole smear campaign.
So it's incredibly frustrating on an
individual level.
But then when they have institutional
support of this stuff,
then when they have woven their
tentacles into academia in,
into,
you know,
very high positions and it's across the
United States,
western Europe.
And again,
remember there is a hierarchy of things
you can't talk about.
You know,
th there is and if you want to figure
something,
if you can figure out the relationship,
you mean this would be epic.
You figure out why.
I love my freedom of language with you
here on the show and you figure out why
of feminists are in bed with Islamists.
And then we got something because this
to me is one of the most bizarre,
fascinating,
disturbing,
grotesque.
I mean,
if there were ever a group who actively,
you know,
it's even worse than the form Baltic
states and the Soviet Union who,
the only military alliance in history,
their primary objective was to attack
themselves.
This is even worse than that.
I mean these people,
you could not possibly find a group of
people who are more antithetical to the
most rudimentary feminist values than
the Islamists.
It is not possible.
Never has it existed,
but yet these people are in bed with
each other and it happens over and over
again.
I mean,
this situation where you're laughing,
it's awesome.
I mean,
it's true.
It's just,
it's the poetry of the bizarre.
Yeah,
it is.
It's,
it's,
it's some bizarre folly.
It's very strange.
It's very strange,
but it's they're brown and you that you
can't,
that's part of the bad about Brown
people.
You can openly mock Christians.
Yeah,
that that's right you,
you can,
you can mock Christians.
There's something about a skin color
that that trumps other things to think
about that for a second.
These people,
the only people who care,
this isn't my line,
I read this somewhere,
but the only people who care about race
are racists and regressive leftist.
These people are,
look,
the regressive left really are the new
racist.
They were really looking at everything
in terms of race and sex and I think
there's a lot of sense of sex.
There's a lot of sexism in the
regressive left because they don't
really like men and there's a lot of
anti unmasculine ideology that gets
perpetrated on people.
The point where you thinking like you're
supposed to be more soft gendered,
gender supposed to be a fluid thing,
like you're not supposed to be overtly
masculine.
That's nonsense.
How come you can be overtly feminine
once you become transgender?
How come?
How come you,
if a woman wants to wear like a pushup
Bra,
have our tits poking out in a short
skirt and high heels and a lot of makeup
and do her hair up.
That girl's giving into the patriarchy,
but if a transgender does it,
you go,
girl.
If a transgender man all of a sudden
adopts those traditionally feminine
views,
it hypocrisy.
But it's even worse than hypocrisy
because if it just stopped there,
it would be something.
But it's this idea that these people,
they think that they can dictate to
other people how they should live.
Yeah.
When you see a guy who's a power lifter,
okay.
Some big fucking giant,
like you know that game of thrones,
the mountain guy,
the mountain guys.
I met that guy.
That's why I didn't say hi to him.
I saw him.
He was at the UFC this past weekend.
He's a fucking gigantic man.
It's huge.
He a whole thing with conor mcgregor.
Yeah.
It's awesome.
He obviously likes being fucking huge.
He enjoys picking shit up and moving it
around.
He enjoys breaking records.
What do I give a fuck?
Why would I care?
He seems like a nice guy,
like the idea that this it,
even if he's an Asshole,
what?
Well,
here's the thing is,
but he's,
he doesn't seem to be,
and that my point is like there's no,
he's,
he's not doing anything terrible like,
but you would look at that and decide
that this person living their life in
this way is negative.
That he's masculine and he's a part of
the problem and rape culture and all
this Jay.
No,
he's just picking big shit up and moving
it around and flexing the most innocuous
thing,
right?
That blood could do.
Well,
why is it mean?
Why is it because he's overtly
masculine?
Why is that bad?
Like what if he just put the same amount
of energy into swimming and this guy
just like to swim across the fucking
ocean?
Would you freak out about that?
No.
It's like,
it's,
it's this feeling,
this guy is becoming this thing that you
find impressive even if he's not doing
any of that yet.
So,
so it's ticked.
So they're already a logs.
We got that and they subscribe to ideas
that are just not in accordance with
reality.
And I think,
and I'm not using the term regressive
here,
I think general liberals in general tend
to believe that if we can change social
system somehow and,
and,
and I,
I think that there's a lot of truth in
this.
Uh,
Steven Steven pinker kind of,
uh,
in the blank slate,
deconstruct some of these ideas,
but liberals kind of think if you could
only change the institutions in society,
then things would by definition be more
fair and more equal.
We're all born blank slates and you
know,
it's all of these disparities and
inequality has come about as a result
of,
uh,
problems within the system despite
inequalities when the system and this
look,
unless you are really an ideolog on the
right,
you would be hard pressed to say,
you know,
why,
why shouldn't we try to do our best to
create systems of justice that are more
fair?
I'm a big Fan of John Ralston.
Any reasonable person would say that,
but these people,
they don't believe in differences be,
they think that they're,
they're non bile.
The differences between men and women
are not biological.
They think that their cultural
artifacts,
they think that,
you know,
and I don't know if you want to get the
whole race thing,
but the race thing is another thing.
But they think that race is only skin
deep there.
It's a social construct.
You know,
rather than saying,
well,
why do Jewish women get [inaudible]
syndrome?
Wider Black Guy,
black people get more sickle cell
anemia.
Um,
but again,
you know,
I,
I notice my hesitancy in discussing
these things because I know that anytime
you bring this up,
this is an opportunity for people to
smear.
You tell you you're a bigot,
a racist or a homophobe and,
and,
oh,
and it's also the pinnacle of identity
politics where the things that I say are
discredited or they look at me because
I'm,
I'm situated in the body than I am for
the sexuality.
I had no choice over whatsoever.
And they used that as an opportunity to
discredit my speech.
I mean the whole thing is just,
it's,
it is literally if you could say,
well let's,
let's make a list of all the things that
we can write down to make it impossible
to solve our problems.
These people,
they have the list.
I mean they have the gold standard for
the list.
Yeah,
it's a very good point.
I mean I think one of the most important
aspects of this is what you said about
silencing debate and that debate and
discussion
is the only way we figure things out.
And I don't know,
I've met you today.
I know you because of your work.
I know you because of your associations
with friends of mine,
like Sam Harris.
But I don't know your thinking until I
talked to you and when I talked to you I
go,
oh,
okay,
I see how he sees that.
Or he sees things in a different way and
it's hard for people to do that because
we have this rigid set ideas that we
have
in our head and we would like to
reinforce those on everybody because it
makes life simpler.
Well,
if you think the way I think,
and I think the way you think it's
perfect,
right?
So that's when we bring Jujitsu and
again,
right?
So that's why the problem is when we
hang out with people who only believe
like we do,
it's called the filter bubble.
Uh,
and the,
and it's a book about it called the beat
big sort.
We tend to be more confident in the
beliefs that we have,
right?
But what we should be doing is we should
be going to different gyms,
right?
You should be going as your buddy to
10th planet,
you should be going and checking out
different things because you need to
test these ideas to see if they work in
the same way we should be listening to
ideas.
It's a problem if you're a liberal and
you only listen to liberal stuff or an
atheist and you only listen.
You really need to listen to challenge
and engage yourself by opening yourself
up to these experiences and starting
with the possibility that you could be
wrong.
So if you're a black belt in Brazilian
Jujitsu and you walk into someone's
school and the blue belts are routinely
tapping you do,
you got to do some thinking.
Yeah,
you're going to be honest with yourself
and it doesn't matter how much time
you've put into it,
it doesn't matter what your commitment
is,
what matters is what works.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
And that is a beautiful thing about high
level problem solving in martial arts
that if it works,
it works.
And it's,
it's hard to do that when it comes to
ideas like compassion and justice and
getting along and how you should treat
people and how people should be
accepted.
And you know,
there's,
there's things about diversity and about
a quality that I think we all agree
with.
I mean I think you shouldn't be judged
by your sexuality or what you look like
or where you were born or you know,
fill in the blank.
Nationalism seems to be kind of fucking
silly to me.
I think you should judge people on how
you behave and how you interact with
each other and be like,
do I enjoy talking to this person?
And guess what?
You might enjoy talking to me,
but somebody else might fucking think
I'm a moron.
They might not like talk to me.
And that's their prerogative to.
They can.
You don't have to just because you like
Peter Boghossian.
Just because you enjoy people,
it doesn't mean I have to enjoy them.
You know,
I have friends that have friends.
I can't fucking stand,
you know,
and I'll be around like,
oh Christ,
why are you hanging around with this
guy?
He gives me headaches.
I gotta get Outta here.
And the the older,
yeah,
the older I get,
the more I,
I just want to spend my time with
people.
I really want to spend money and not
obligations.
You can't fix people.
I've tried so fucking hard to get along
with people that are unmotivated or lazy
or they have constant problems in their
life.
They don't look at themselves objective
Lee.
And you talk to them about things that
happen in their life and they have a
fucking myriad of excuses.
It's overwhelming and that you,
if you have those people in your life,
they will overwhelm you with their
issues and you will never get anything
done.
And so my take is try until you can't
try and then get the fuck out of there.
Yeah.
And you,
you're already doing what you're doing.
And is that you're modeling those
behaviors.
You know,
when my,
I was just talking to my buddy the other
day,
he's,
he's upset that all their aggressives
are attacking him.
And I just said,
just,
I'll publish everybody.
No,
that's the currency in academia.
Like what do you care,
like just publish and explain your
thoughts in a way that will inspire
debate and aspire thought.
Explain your thoughts in a blog in a way
where people can read it and like it and
share it with friends.
And that's one of the beautiful things
about today is that you have this
ability that's never literally
unparalleled access to other human
beings.
It's never been like this where you
could just write something.
You put it on facebook.
You could be a carpenter in Kansas and
you write something beautiful on
facebook and it'll be shared across the
world within minutes.
Yeah.
I'll add one more thing to that and
don't treat people if you've been
treated negatively by people.
Don't stoop to that.
It's hard.
Right?
It's hard for people.
Yeah.
My Mentor,
my mentor,
this is somewhat of a of a non sequitur,
but my metro told me this really fast
Dalai Lama story.
No,
no.
The Pope No.
Did the one that just got rid of right.
Then what?
The child molester pope,
he told me he was a,
he's 97 and he's a survivor of a book
involved.
Yeah.
It's a really amazing guys that Phil
about his life and he went back and
liberated the same,
yeah,
same
concentration camp told me the story
about chickens.
That was a very profound in my life.
Basically.
I think he was on the study.
If not then,
but it doesn't make a difference.
Basically they,
they wanted to see if they could reverse
the pecking order among chickens.
And there's something that's a literal
pecking order.
And then if you put chickens in a coop,
seven chickens,
chicken,
one will peck chicken to chicken,
one would pet chickens two through seven
but never be picked chicken too will not
pet chicken one.
But we'll pick,
check it patrick.
So the same thing all the way down.
Chick chicken seven gets packed by all
the chickens and pex nobody.
So they wanted to see if they could
reverse the pecking order.
And I think that this story has profound
implications for all of life.
And so what they did was they put a
little color,
they put little collars on all the
chickens and when the chicken raised his
head as if it was going to pack into the
chicken,
they zapped it.
Now here's the question to you,
and I got it wrong.
When he asked me,
do you think it was easier to make
chicken one chicken seven or chicken
seven chicken one chicken seven chicken
one.
See,
that's what I said.
That's wrong.
And here's the reasoning for that
chicken seven has been,
has been,
I'm not plugged duct correct peck,
peck,
thanks has been pecked at whole life.
It's,
it's,
it's all only going to get packed and
only takes one shock.
And I'll tell you another very quick
story.
It only takes one shock of chicken,
one to make a chicken seven instantly.
Really?
Yeah,
because it's never experienced that.
That's why,
for example,
in the criminal justice system,
harsh punishments don't work.
They just don't.
And that's borne out by overwhelming
empirical evidence.
But I think a theoretical background for
that is the chicken story.
That's why like my,
he was telling me that when his son,
he never yelled at his son is a funny
story looking at you with all the
tattoos and his son wanted to get a
tattoo and he slammed his hand down and
he said No.
And he screamed and his son was so
shocked.
It was like such a shocking thing
because he had never raised his voice.
He always been chicken one,
you know he had always been,
but when you really start to think about
the implications of that,
of what kindness will do,
of what,
of why being,
there's your word again for two
creative,
nasty,
harsh to people.
The best way to change moral attitudes
is through rapport.
The best way to help people,
and if you read the the Christian books,
they talk about this interesting book
called tactics and the main thing is,
you know,
develop relationships with people.
They're friendly,
they're kind,
they're trustworthy of communities with
people and that gets them involved in
their community and thus their faith
based blood.
Same thing with Jujitsu.
I have like some great guys I was just
hanging out with the other day who do
Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is also interesting just
parenthetically because you have such a
trust of the people you work out with.
I mean you have a bond.
A buddy of mine is a prosecutor for the
state and you know how you have to say,
Hey,
I know this guy.
When he knew another guy who's also a
friend of mine and they did Jujitsu
together and he told the judge and the
lawyer and they said they have,
they don't have a problem with it.
Neither one of those people do Jujitsu.
Right.
Because there's no freaking way that I
would let someone do Jujitsu,
sit on a jury with somebody else who's
either the prosecutor,
the defender,
because those people trust each other
because you have to trust each other
when you do Jujitsu or people will break
your arm still choke deck.
You're also part of a very tight knit
and unusual community.
Absolutely.
You have this bond with each other that
I don't think people understand your,
your practice and killing each other.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
You're practicing breaking each other's
arms.
Yeah.
So I think that that,
that chicken story,
and I told that because often we think
that the best response to be when,
when we're being mistreated or we
perceive an injustice or unfairness just
to lash out and a type of emotional
maturity is just to not lash out.
You know,
maybe a really good strategy which I've
adopted instead of,
it's certainly much easier than,
than attempting to do the emotional work
of being kind and compassionate is just,
just ignore people.
You don't have to meet their nastiness
with nastiness.
You just walk away.
Well that's a good approach.
If he could pull it off,
sometimes people get pissed off,
told you like fuck this guy.
Ah,
but I think that also is what I call the
battery effect.
And it's also a good aspect of Jujitsu.
I think beings have
a certain amount of energy that they
store up in their body because I think
we have,
our bodies are,
we have this ancient structure that it's
been passed on from generation to
generation,
thousands and thousands of years of
human beings.
And for the most part up until really
recently you were constantly engaged in
physical activity and conflict and your
body is designed for that.
And I believe your body has a certain
amount of requirements for the
expenditure of energy.
And when you don't meet those
requirements,
your battery overflows.
And I think that's what road rage is.
And I think that's what,
uh,
irrational responses.
And I know personally from my own
experience in my own shortcomings when I
have had irrational responses is because
I have not maintained my body correctly
and I have not taken care of that
battery.
And then when it comes up,
especially when you're someone like me,
it's even more consequential because
I've done it my whole life.
So my whole life has been about
exploding,
punching,
kicking.
I'm just all look kettlebells,
Jujitsu,
there's all this,
Rah,
Rah.
And in doing that,
if I get it out of my system,
I'm tranquil.
Everything's calm.
But when I don't get out of my system
was about my body.
It's like,
I think this is an opportunity to go
fuck a class.
You got all this extra,
you know what I mean?
It's like if you bought,
he's like,
come on bitch.
You're like,
it's,
it's stored up.
You've got too much juice in your
battery.
And Jujitsu people for the most part are
some of the most mellow,
calm and relaxed people outside of it.
They also have the benefit of knowing
that the average person literally has no
idea how to defend themselves.
We know this because we have been
personally humiliated as an average
person going into Jujitsu and then you
become a practitioner and you become
fairly proficient and then you
understand your limitations,
but you also understand much more deeply
the limitations of the average person.
Absolutely.
No,
you,
you haven't.
Having an at from my perspective and
encyclopedic knowledge of martial arts
and lineages and people in my
experience,
the people I've met like,
like,
uh,
you know,
um,
I'm trying to think of,
uh,
um,
John Kavanagh I'd be a good example.
He's a very,
very deep,
have you ever role with John?
No.
He's very good.
Like he's extraordinarily good.
I'm sure he is.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
He's a super good guy.
The people you meet who are just the
most dangerous,
deadly people,
they're just,
they got nothing to prove.
Yeah.
They seem to be the nicest people you
ever met Marcella Garcia?
No.
He's the sweetest of sweeties.
He's just like a smiling,
happy assassin.
Yeah.
When you're around him,
he's so nice.
He's just such a nice guy.
And Yeah,
when you're around them,
my friend Eddie Bravo is fucking nicest
guy ever.
He's always nice.
Yeah.
And then,
and then as I went out to a bar a little
while ago,
and a guy had a black belt around his
waist as a belt and he was playing pool
and I thought to myself,
this guy has some issues.
It was a dangling a,
you know how you tie a belt around a g?
He was tied it around his pants like
that.
So like,
like the,
the,
the two were dangling like
a black belt with me.
So he wanted to let everybody know that
he's a black belt.
You know,
you just buy a black belt.
That's the other thing I tell people,
like,
like you can get a black belt from like
online,
you buy them and then they come and then
you put it on.
Like you don't have to earn it.
It's not like,
it's like a sacred forging ground,
black belts where there's only one way
to just pay a lot of money.
You don't even have to fucking do a
fantasy martial art.
You could just be a regular guy or a
black belt.
I mean,
you literally can,
there was a video really recently.
I mean,
it still does happen to this day.
If some guy showing up at a Brazilian
Jujitsu school,
he puts on a game,
I think he had a wrestling shoes on and
a black belt and a,
he showed up at this gym and he started
a working out with people.
And then the instructor realized
immediately that this guy was not a
black belt and humiliated him and punish
him and tell him to take the belt off
and get the fuck outta here.
And he was screaming at him.
But see,
that's the beauty of Jujitsu too,
is you can't pretend,
cannot pretend.
Yeah.
You can pretend in some martial arts,
I mean there's guys that invent moves
that they think,
like with this,
one of my favorite videos as these guys
in Harlem,
it's not videos.
There's a series of them who practice
some,
some sort of fake Kung Fu.
And like one guy will,
uh,
will be like,
he'll throw a punch and then the other
guy will go,
well if someone does that to me when I'm
going to do is,
um,
they,
they don't say it like this.
They say it in a very urban way.
Like not,
I'm not,
that shit ain't gonna work cause I'm
gonna step over here and I'm attack with
a chicken wing and then I got a,
I got a monkey Paul and they invent all
this stuff on my attack your ribs for
this position.
And then their guys also in on it
because they're also practicing
bullshit.
It's like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I see how that would work.
Well,
what's hilarious is sometimes these guys
actually have fights and when they have
fights it becomes like two kids in a
fucking school yard.
It becomes a,
a brawl on the ground.
These wind up clawing at each other and
they can't do anything.
There's no Kung Fu.
There's no monkey paw.
There's no attack the ribs with your
knife point fingers and all this stupid
shit.
But you watch these guys do it.
And me as a person who studied martial
arts my whole life.
I know I don't practice Kung Fu,
but I know what is actually Kung Fu and
what is some shit that someone's making
up.
They're just practicing and making
things up.
Well,
they could go to even a common food dojo
and try and pretend that that stuff's
real and the Kung Fu guy would go like,
what are you talking about?
Like this?
You're inventing things.
Don't you feel bad for those guys at
some level?
Yes,
I do.
I think that a lot of those guys,
if they had just found the correct path,
would benefit greatly if they just found
a real martial arts school.
Okay.
So here's what I think part of it is,
I think that they engage,
and I'm really interested to hear what
you think about this.
I think that they engage in a
willingness to self deceive.
Oh,
a hundred percent yeah,
100% yeah.
And they,
it's mutual.
It's with both people.
Like they,
they,
you know,
reinforce each other.
You see it in religion too though.
You see that in religion?
God finds a way.
Yes he does.
God does find a way.
Meanwhile they leave and smoke crack and
suck some dude's Dick people are crazy.
I mean,
that's what they do.
They pretend,
they pretend and they loved.
One of the things that people love about
Christians and Christians love about
Christians and he's like,
well,
I'm a Christian.
I'm a Christian too,
right?
They you're saying no.
Yes.
Tribalism.
And also,
I know that at least in the moment,
you are going to engage in some very
predictable behavior.
You're going to engage in,
uh,
you're,
you're a god feeling fear and Christian
man.
So you're going to behave like a god
fearing Christian man,
and you're going to say things
[inaudible] I know where you're coming
from.
You're not some fucking Weirdo Buddhist
Zen dude who likes to do payoti now
you're,
you're real clear.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
so it's real clear.
You like country music.
Are you Luke Bryan Fan Bait to,
well,
of course you've got a pickup truck off
course and I've got,
oh,
I've got a belt buckle.
I've got a big belt buckle.
Do you know what about your boots?
Look at my boots or cowboy boots.
You know,
it's like we,
we engage in these really predictable
patterns and people find comfort in
those patterns.
Yeah.
And we tend to like people who are like
ourselves.
Yes,
yes.
It's very much a tribalism thing and
it's,
it's also very much,
it reinforces your,
like if you have a lack of willingness
or ability or whatever it is to question
the reality that you have been shown
that you have subscribed to.
If you have,
if you're not willing to question it and
you find someone else who was also not
willing to question it,
there's some comfort in that.
And if you reassure each other,
there's some comfortable,
that's absolutely right.
And that's why it's so important for
people to be honest with themselves.
And how do,
how do we promote those values of people
of self honesty this way?
I think that is exactly what
conversations,
I think this is the way you do it.
And especially the conversation like
this that will be heard by more than a
million people.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's the way you do it.
And I mean,
I'm just saying those Willem doing broom
to fix in the world,
but I'm saying humans talking to each
other through social media,
through,
I want various math,
I'll just throw this out now.
I wonder if,
you know,
everyone's like,
oh,
you know,
would come after postmodernism,
whatever.
I wonder if this comes after
postmodernism.
I mean,
I wonder if these truth telling
conversations come after postmodernism.
Why say I certainly think there's a
great benefit to talking to people and
having people be honest and even in an
uncomfortable way where when you
listened to it,
it makes you think,
oh,
there's lights that go on in my head
when I hear someone say something,
maybe maybe they'll be vulnerable or
maybe there'll be like introspective and
almost a painful way when I hear it,
there's lights that go on in my head
while I go,
wow,
okay,
I'm getting some real shit from this
person and I'll find in myself these
moments that relate to what this guy is
saying.
And I,
I,
I try to see themselves from this point
of view as opposed to a newscaster.
When someone is,
uh,
today in Los Angeles,
we found out the hard way.
What happens when you don't obey the
law?
There's no re
reality.
There's no,
there's,
there's no human in there.
This is a strip club dj coming up on the
main stage.
It's lexus $14 Comma cozzies order now.
You know what I mean?
It's like these are patterns that are
not real,
that people subscribe to and adopt and
then perpetrate and,
and they do it over and over again in
the business world.
Hello Jim.
How's the family?
Is Everything good?
These patterns are like,
they protect you from having to be
vulnerable and real.
They buy by adopting these predetermined
patterns of behavior that we all are
comfortable with and we all know as a
god fearing Christian man,
well,
I'm a god fearing Christian man,
myself,
swap.
I don't understand where you're coming
from there sir.
Give me a handshake right now on the,
we're on the same page that what they're
doing is they,
they're,
they're removing the possibility of
vulnerability and of,
of reality and authenticity.
Yes.
Authenticity is the perfect word and
that,
that makes me sad for them.
It really does.
It's,
it's a type of tragedy when you get sad
of the shit that I don't get sad.
I get sad at cartoons.
Well,
I don't get set of cartoons,
but I do feel the impetus to help people
like that.
Like I do feel that it's important that
that people are laboring under beliefs
about reality.
Like again,
fantasy based martial arts that just
simply aren't true and they're wasting
their time.
But unlike fantasy martial arts,
these people vote and these people
affect decisions.
They directly affect my life.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Especially social issues comes a real
problem.
You know,
it becomes a real problem when you start
blocking people's access to certain
medical procedures and deciding what can
and can be done based on,
I mean,
look at what was happening during the
Bush administration when it comes to,
when it came to stem cell research,
right?
I mean it was fucking shackled and
stopped because everybody,
they're gold sail bay bees and they go,
they're going to kill babies and just
get the stem cells from embryos and
said,
Satan mean stem cells from skin you
fuck.
And meanwhile the rest of the world,
it has like advanced in progress.
Do you know the Indians and South
Koreans?
Yeah.
I mean it's just we got fucked by
religious ideology.
Got in the way of medical innovation.
Yeah,
it's Itchy I think.
I think part of this is,
I've been thinking about this a lot.
I think part of this,
a way that we can at least dent this
problem is by promoting the value of
honesty.
Because if we promote the value of
honesty,
then with that comes the willingness to
revise people's beliefs and we have to
make it okay to say,
I don't know,
like I'm totally cool.
It's you sitting here and you talk about
all these guys.
I don't know all that stuff.
I think that's one of the beautiful
things about this new age of information
is that is impossible now clearly to
know everything.
No one can know everything,
so it's okay to say,
I don't know now where it used to be a
sign of you are poorly motivated,
are poorly educated or what?
I mean I'm not very educated.
I went to college for three years.
I barely paid attention and I only did
it because I didn't want people to think
I was a loser.
I barely made it out of high school,
but since that time I've read a lot of
shit,
have watched a lot of documentaries,
I've had a lot of fascinating
conversations with people and I've
accumulated some information.
So am I educated?
Not really,
but yeah,
I mean I'm an educated on certain things
about light.
I would say maybe not formally educated.
What does that,
you know,
where,
where is formality now when you have
formal education?
Like what's going on with your school?
Wait,
question.
Not La sit now.
All schools,
all schools.
What is it now?
Because that's not education.
You're,
you're,
you're being indoctrinated into this
ridiculous ideology.
If you're participating in that kind of
shit,
it's worse than it's anti education.
It's like Kata.
Yeah.
It's in a lot of ways.
In a lot of ways.
It is.
Um,
it is just like religion and,
and that's what my friend Kurt Metzger
was saying about the social justice
warriors.
He's like,
no,
I,
I've seen this.
I grew up in a fucking call.
I know what this is.
You're telling me I can't think about it
any other way.
And that's bullshit.
And his reaction to it is very bright.
He gets angry at it and you know,
and he's not like a violent guy,
but he's just like,
it was like,
this is fucking bullshit.
I know what it is,
is bullshit.
You're,
you're making me think a certain way.
I'm not doing it.
Yeah.
And in the bigger picture of things,
you know,
America has been,
this is a somewhat of a controversial
statement,
but,
but we're,
we're not the great superpower we used
to be,
but the one thing that we make for
yourself,
the one thing we've always had is we've
had strong institutions and strong
universities and now we're seeing those
being undermined,
at least in the humanities in general
and even to a certain extent in the
sciences and it,
it,
I don't assign it.
See,
I guess what I said,
I think,
cause I don't,
I don't really know because I'm not in
the sciences so I can't speak to that.
But just anecdotally from what I've
heard of people,
but again,
can't,
I can't,
I can't speak to that.
You know,
I was thinking about,
but anecdotally can come up with
specific examples because that's where I
haven't heard it interfered with except
for the idea of promoting more women in
science and there's some how or another,
some sex.
That's what I was in science.
What I was thinking.
So,
so here's the problem with that.
Why are there no diversity requirements
with sports teams that will write like
football teams,
how come they don't need to have a
certain amount of women because they
want to win,
but also they don't want women to get
killed,
right?
So that's different because it's
physical.
Okay,
well why?
Why aren't they say,
well we need so many Puerto Ricans here
or we need so many,
there aren't diversity requirements.
So here's a word flight exogenous.
It's like an X.
I know that word.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
So because because they want to win.
In other words,
they're telling you this is important to
us.
Anytime you impose a value on a system
that is,
that is winning is the value
and that's an marketplace,
right?
Right.
That's a con competition.
That's a free market.
Anytime you say,
well,
you know you also need diversity,
then you're making it more difficult to,
to win a meritocracy is like that.
Like you,
you want people in a system to have in,
in academia,
I can tell you what those are.
You need to be well published.
You had works need to be cited by
others.
You need to have the,
we have all these metrics,
they're,
they're pretty straightforward and you
either live up to the metrics or you
don't.
But now this is why I was talking about
the sciences.
When you tried to put people in
positions who are not qualified for
those positions,
you undermine the meritocracy.
So when you're trying to put people,
if you say,
well there's not enough women here,
we need to find more women.
There are not enough African American.
Well enough.
That's a trickier.
But there,
there are very few African Americans who
study philosophy.
If you are an African American with a
phd in philosophy,
may you are your gold.
That is awesome.
So an African American with a phd for
philosophy can kind of write their own
ticket.
Yeah.
[inaudible] a good thing cause they want
to promote more African Americans get
involved in philosophy and then perhaps
that will sort of engage more people
doing that.
Now this is now,
this is a really interesting
conversation that we should have.
This is the kind of thing at this point
in academia,
we have to shut down the discourse
because someone's going to be offended,
but I think that's an important question
because your question is basically it's
a kind of utilitarian calculus like,
okay,
yeah.
Let's say that we have,
what is the,
first of all,
you have to look at the evidence.
Regressives don't like evidence very
much,
but we have to look at the evidence.
What is the evidence?
If there are more African Americans in
philosophy,
can they mentor more African American
students,
et Cetera.
Of course.
I would think that we would want that.
That would be a good thing.
That would be something that would be
wonderful.
The question is,
does that mean that we would hire a
candidate who does not,
who would not be hired if that candidate
had a different skin color?
Right?
Like that whole thing undermines the
meritocracy,
but the moment that you start talking
about putting a diversity requirement
on,
for example,
my discipline philosophy,
in essence,
I think what you're saying is it's not
important.
Your discipline isn't important because
we don't do that when the outcome really
matters.
We don't do that with brain surgery.
We don't do that with sports teams.
So we're not looking for the best
candidates.
What we're looking for is to bring
people into these disciplines that may
not have had the opportunity and that
might be bad for the overall discipline.
Yeah,
it's bad for the overall institution.
It's bad for the discipline,
but because you're not finding the best
people,
but the idea is that you're trying to
promote these disciplines in places
where people aren't,
as it were not represented,
but also they don't have the same
advantages.
They don't have privileges there,
don't have good as privileged as another
word we talked about.
So,
so they're underrepresented.
So we want more people to discipline in
as long as that's not bad in and of
itself,
but we need to have a conversation about
what that means.
See,
part of the problem with regressives is
they look at outcomes instead of
opportunities.
We need to construct systems to give
everybody,
regardless of their skin color,
of their ethnicity and equal opportunity
and an education or the first rate.
And what we're seeing instead is systems
being created to orchestrate or engineer
outcomes produce this many black African
about whatever it is,
or Hispanic,
whatever it is.
The,
first of all,
it's a bad way to think about it.
It's a horrible way to think about it.
But the other problem is in meritocracy
matters we need,
we need to,
if anything should be institutionalized.
It should be systems that are raced,
blind systems that don't look,
think about it.
You could also think about like this,
think about the black guy who is in
philosophy,
who's incredibly smart and qualified.
I have a student of mine,
Matt Hernandez,
that kid is freaking genius,
like truly one in a million,
like much smarter than I am.
He's published off.
I mean he,
the kid's awesome.
He's Hispanic.
He's going to get his phd in philosophy,
got a full ride,
a full scholarship.
The crime.
The shame is that when Matt gets in,
people would say,
well,
he just got it because he's Hispanic.
No,
actually,
no,
he got is going to say that though.
Well,
no one's going to say it.
They're gonna think it.
Well,
that's the problem.
The problem is that we can't have a
conversation to ask people if they're
thinking about it,
because if they say yes,
there'll be smeared as a racist.
Okay.
So then how do you address the issue
with inequality inside of these
marginalized community?
That's a great question.
Look,
this is what I think we need to do when
you look at surveys of if people,
so I think that these lines are
primarily a po on class drawn upon
class,
which is something else no one wants to
talk about instead of race.
It just so happens that,
uh,
fewer African Americans frame it the
other way.
More African Americans have bond born
into poverty then,
then white folks.
That's just the,
that's just a fact.
We can also talk about something that's
really an interesting about criminigenic
factors or risk predictors.
They're not what you think for people
who would be violent criminals did just
not what you think at all.
Uh,
but people try to make that a ratio
issue.
But when you look at these systems,
when you look at these school systems,
for example,
um,
I just totally lost my train of thought.
I started thinking about race and Jimi
Hendrix's photo back there.
Oh,
sorry.
What you were talking about,
um,
trying to get more,
oh yeah.
Addressing the issue of income
inequality.
And so,
so what we need to do is,
well,
we need to start thinking about
opportunities.
Well,
the other thing is we need to think long
term and not short term.
We need to look at the problem and be
honest.
And there are some structural issues
with our electorate and the way that
we've established politics in this
country of offices of four years and
then eight years in numerable.
We need to have a longer term vision in
a look at what this wants to be.
Ah,
Eh,
right now we face a problem and that
we're not adequately educating poor
people in our country.
And the majority of those happened to be
black,
and this is an enormous problem.
This is going to come back to haunt us.
But the solution to that problem is not
diversity initiatives.
That's the,
here's the other reason why that's bad.
It's not even a bandaid.
It's worse.
It's because people then say,
well,
look,
this floss department,
this department has so many minorities,
things must be going well,
actually no,
they're not going well.
It was an artificial solution that was
put in and the underlying structural
inequality and economic disparity hasn't
been addressed.
That's a great way to put it.
And what about all the poor people that
live in West Virginia or Kentucky?
There's families have been generations
and generations of coal miners.
I mean just because other white people
have made it into universities and made
an into certain institutions.
You're being racist if you think that
those people shouldn't get an equal shot
of things as well.
And so the way we fix it is,
again,
this is John rawls idea,
public education in the first rate.
However,
every time I would say that people would
say two things.
They'd play identity politics.
You're just what you're saying that
because you're white,
that gives them,
that's their ticket to discredit what
I'm saying.
That's the,
that's why people,
they use that as an excuse to not listen
to your arguments.
It's really,
it's perverted.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's really despicable.
So,
so,
so the,
so they use that.
They use that idea as an excuse.
So you've just said that.
But the other thing that it does,
I mean if you really start to think
about what kind of society do we want to
move to,
what,
what are the limits of our institutions?
What,
what role should the meritocracy play?
Should you disrupt that?
If there are racial inequalities or
imbalances,
these are questions we have to address.
People had democracy have to address
this and you cannot have fear of talking
about this because someone's going to
call you a racist.
You just can't.
So if you want to put a proposal forward
that says,
or an idea,
well,
I don't think,
you know,
hiring should be this way.
You need to have that conversation.
But there's one other issue.
There's one of the tactic that the
regressive left use and that's the idea
of privilege.
They love that word privilege.
Oh well you know,
you don't even see your privilege.
You don't privileges yet.
Another thing that's used and look,
I,
I think the impetus for that is good.
The danger here is that because these
people are so nasty,
so mean spirited and so generally insane
that we discard everything that they're
saying.
We throw the baby out with the bath
water and now we need to be conscious
and careful that we don't do that.
We need to acknowledge that they're
saying some important things there.
You know,
racial treatment of people in the basis
of race,
gender,
sexual orientation,
not discriminating against someone
because they,
they don't feel comfortable in a male
body or a female or Guy Mark Fisher I
roll with just is a gay and has his
gauges.
Just think these things are important.
These things matter.
These things are things that we have to
talk about and if I have privilege,
I want to be conscious of that in.
If I'm treating someone in a way that's
unjust or if it's unkind,
I,
I want to know about that.
That's not the guy I want to be,
you know,
so,
so how do we talk about these things?
How do we,
how do we engage these?
Well,
here's how you don't talk about them.
You don't talk about them by constantly
smearing people with privilege.
You saying you have privilege,
you're not,
or Portland state my university,
they had an event where students,
minority students were,
were,
you know,
could speak about all these things,
but students who were,
I can't remember the exact phrasing,
not of color,
were invited to listen.
Think about that.
They were invited to listen.
They have institutionalized racism.
That's what that is.
It is.
It certainly racism in that sense.
But isn't it an opportunity for people
that have been marginalized to express
themselves in a platform that maybe a
lot of people that have been
marginalized haven't had the
opportunity?
Isn't there room for people of a
specific race to speak,
uh,
about some issues that maybe they would
understand intimately that you are,
I wouldn't because we're white folks.
There's no question at all that that's
true.
And you know what I was at at bad
though,
to have someone have the opportunity to
like,
let's,
let's allow African Americans speak and
let's allow these white folks to listen
to what they have to say.
And then maybe you have another
conference or maybe a debate or maybe a
conversation where you allow someone to
have a retort.
So the first,
the first problem with that is if you
frame it in terms of an opportunity than
if I say yes,
it's bad,
then it should be like I'm denying
people the opportunity.
So I think that's the best way to frame
it.
Right.
Uh,
the problem with that one price,
my buddy who's an appellate court judge,
and he said one,
he said he thinks it's unwise or his son
actually said this,
he didn't say this.
His son is,
uh,
is a,
on the clerks for some supreme court.
I don't even know what he's put some,
but he has his lawyer,
board certified,
et Cetera,
have a pass the bar.
Excuse me.
Uh,
part of the problem is that if you do
that,
so I was amazed that that was legal.
I'm not a lawyer,
I don't pretend to be a lawyer,
but he said it's actually legal.
The problem is that you then need to
hold than white people or whoever any
other group can hold and say,
look,
blacks can't speak basically.
So we can get in and we can talk about
how great it is.
Good luck with that.
So you're right.
So you're so it's not so you,
you,
you're creating an opportunity for
people who are genuine racists to
undermine the whole system.
But the other thing is like,
I think it's important you can totally
do that and say,
look,
we're going to have people for two hours
speak about their experiences of
oppression.
I think that's great.
And I think that they should do that.
And I think we need to be more sensitive
and I think we need to correct any
structural inequalities or remove biases
that we have with people.
And I'm sure I still have some,
I don't,
I don't know of any,
I try to remove them.
I'm sure.
I still have them.
But the idea is that shouldn't people of
any race then be allowed to ask people
questions about those experiences?
Shouldn't we then say,
Oh,
you've had this experiences of,
you know,
gang Jujitsu again,
whatever it is,
or being black in the academy are being,
uh,
like you said this,
like,
I don't know how to explain that to me.
Explain that to all know.
So you shutting down possibilities for
people who don't understand those.
That's the way we understand things.
We come to understand through asking
questions like,
you know,
Oh,
well why do you do the rear naked choke
list?
Why?
Oh,
because if you don't,
the guy will pull your arm off so you
put in the back of his head.
So like,
we need environments that,
uh,
encourage genuine inquirers and
questions and that here's the problem so
that someone could say,
well,
what if someone goes in there and starts
shouting racial epitaphs or horrible
things?
Okay,
well there are a bad person.
Well,
they're horrible.
They're a file person.
But that's a,
that's what should be clear to
everybody.
And the only way that's going to be
clear to everybody is if you allow open
thinking,
open speech and allow people to express
themselves and you accumulate all that
data and you get an understanding of
what is okay and what's not okay,
what's hurtful,
what's not hurtful.
And if you're constantly in an
environment where you don't even,
you know,
the monkey hear no evil,
you can't even hear a bad idea when
someone does something legitimately
horrible,
what would the reaction be?
Your threshold.
We'll constantly be decreasing.
If you're not hearing ideas right?
If you're not hearing ideas that run
contrary or you know,
challenging than your threshold for what
you find offensive will constantly
lower.
So then anything will offend you.
I had Thaddeus Russell on,
uh,
who's a great guy and he teaches at a
occidental and we were talking about
that,
um,
issue where there was a,
a young man and a young woman who got
together and they got drunk and they had
some consent.
The girl decided that,
uh,
either she decided,
her friends convinced her into it,
that she had been raped even though she
had sent him a bunch of text messages
saying,
are you coming over?
Bring condoms,
told their friends I'm getting laid,
lol.
And uh,
he had gotten to her,
they were both intoxicated,
but because he's a man,
he was kicked off the campus.
He was kicked out of school.
He's,
they're suing is a big lawsuit.
She stayed,
they both sex.
There was no
force.
There was no,
there was no,
no lies.
There's no,
no one held anyone down.
No one did,
did anything against anyone's will.
But they had decided that he had
committed sexual assault because they
were both drunk and they could not
consent,
which is fucking insane.
End Rady.
Ready?
Sexist.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's sexist.
It's sexist towards men.
And if that's just in the pot,
it just,
it disempowers women.
Yes,
it does.
It also,
it's ridiculous because how come you are
responsible for your own actions and
every other realm?
If you drive a car and you're drunk,
you can't say,
well,
Hey,
I was drunk.
I'm not responsible for plowing into
that fucking school bus full of kids.
You can't say that.
But if you say,
hey,
I was drunk.
I'm not responsible for my consent to
have sex with this man.
That was preposterous.
We all know that alcohol limits your
inhibitions.
It lowers your inhibitions and it makes
you do things you might regret.
But there's a,
there's a big thing amongst people
online that are trying to say this and
pass it on.
Regret does not equal rape.
People make mistakes.
We've all made mistakes.
Everyone's made was,
and if you drink,
you're going to make more mistakes.
That's just a fact.
But that doesn't mean that the person
you made a mistake with is a fucking
rapist.
Now,
they've also made a mistake and maybe
not,
maybe,
maybe you guys just had sex and maybe
you're around a bunch of fucking nutty
people who are trying to convince you
that anytime you have sex and you're
drunk,
you've been raped and there is a lot of
that too loud.
So I was going to say that's a cultural
problem.
Now look at it from the view of the
administrator.
Right?
So from the view of the administrator,
students,
Dell,
after his job and those guys have
couched jobs,
man,
they have cush up 300,000.
They get parking spaces and everything.
I mean they have parking spaces are big.
Parking spaces are huge.
The sign Mr. Wilson to sign it just is
ready.
Let me sweep it.
Pulling your test Ya.
Yeah.
So,
so the Tesla,
so,
so those guys,
um,
so,
so those,
those administrative guys as a
microaggression,
how dare you microaggressed me.
So those,
those folks,
I prefer Z.
Yeah.
Oh,
which is funny,
a funny story.
There's a story at U s s story about at
the university about this.
So again,
I have no problem calling somebody,
you know,
he looks like a she or whatever you
want.
Hit a couple of quick stories.
So I had a,
I take attendance.
It's long story,
why I take attendance,
just run with it.
So I get this,
uh,
this very attractive young woman comes
up to me at the end of class.
I'm kind of discombobulated,
got all the shit in my head and she
hands me this note.
And so you can get out of it if you have
a jury duty military orders,
um,
doctor's note,
uh,
excuse from my boss's boss,
the dean or whatever.
So in that way,
and just in case I'm audited,
right,
if I'm audited,
I can say,
or I,
if I say,
hey,
why did this person get off of this?
But I didn't,
you know,
do anything.
And then next thing you know,
she's paying me,
I'm sleeping with who know,
it just,
it's just so much easier for me.
So I'm reading this note and it said,
would you please excuse Mr. So,
and from this
thing and his,
his sis system is,
but whatever it was.
And I'm looking at this like,
who's,
who's Mr Saul and saul and I lived as a,
I don't,
I'm so w is their friends,
I don't know have any idealize what
she's handing me this note should own.
I'm,
I'm Mr so and so.
And it took me a second and it took me a
moment.
I had to like process that I didn't say
anything about it.
I'm like,
oh,
that's great.
Because if I do,
you know,
if people do demand something and,
and they'll say,
well look,
this person gave you this,
this is not a Mr. And like you have a
problem with that.
I mean,
I can pull the same regressive card that
they can you,
you're being homophobic,
you're being transphobic or whatever it
is.
So,
so people have been choosing their own
pronouns.
But the craziest thing that happened to
a colleague of mine is he was told that,
and again,
I call anybody any pronoun you want,
you want to be called Z.
I've got no,
I got bigger shit to where the h e m
problem.
That's three e's.
I'll spell it out for you every time.
Sh so,
so this person wanted to be called,
uh,
I can't remember what the days were,
but certainly
daisy,
he,
she mm.
And he made it
mistake,
my colleague made a mistake and all hell
broke loose.
What was the mistake?
He calls pushy on the wrong thing like
that.
Yeah.
And,
and she said,
you know,
okay,
don't do that again.
And evidently he did that again or
something.
I don't know.
So now
whatever happened to people just being
fucking crazy.
It's not an option.
Is that possible?
You know,
I was watching a video listening to a
radio lab podcast and they were
interviewing this guy who got a guy.
Sometimes,
sometimes it's a girl,
sometimes it goes back and forth and his
gender is fluid and in the middle of the
conversations like I just switched.
I'm a guy now.
I just switched.
I just felt it.
It was immediate.
Like I'm listening to this and I'm
going,
well,
this is a fucking idiot.
Clearly this is obviously a nutty person
that has a very loose,
slippery mineral oil grip on reality.
It's like what just flies were out of
their fingers and they want you to give
in to this slippery reality and focus on
them constantly.
Now he now mushy.
It's another way to divert attention
from anything that's going on and focus
it on them and something completely
trivial like that.
They decide there are female,
they decided they're a male.
What?
What the fuck are you talking about?
And I don't even,
I don't even care if,
if it's pointless piece feel different.
Different Times of the day.
If you feel different sexually,
if you're,
you know,
you're pansexual or it's just you're
just thinking too much and projecting,
you're projecting that off on other
people.
If you really think that you become
transgender,
we assist gender and all like it
switches back and forth all throughout
the day.
You're probably fucking crazy.
Was it?
Was it you who tweeted the link about
the guy who is a six year old girl or
eight year old girl is 52 year old man
and a,
he's a father and he has decided that
now he's a six year old girl.
All right.
I love it.
He should be a six year old fox.
I'm a,
I'm going to be a Fox.
No,
I'm an owl.
I'm an eagle.
I identify with trees.
I'm just going to stand here.
Don't judge.
So,
so instead of,
so here's,
so have a hat with apple's hanging from
it that don't disrespect this is real.
So I think that's part of the problem
with not being able to Morley triage,
right?
It's part of the problem with not being
triage is a great way to describe it
too.
That's a great way to his crime.
So,
so instead of saying,
okay,
look,
this guy,
whatever's going on in his,
her life person,
that's Z,
whatever,
fine,
great run with it.
I,
it's just not,
it's not worth my time.
Yeah.
If a guy wants to be trivial world girl,
you go forward.
I think we have a problem with mister
and misses and all that shit.
How about we just abandoned it.
Your name's Peter.
My name's Joe and make a fucking noise.
That means that's like my,
my,
my issue with this whole Caitlin Jenner
thing.
Cause like you have to call her Caitlyn
now.
It's a shitty car.
Caitlin,
I've been calling this fucking person is
one noise that I make with my mouth my
whole life.
In the Diane Sawyer interview,
he said he and he said,
Bruce,
I'm sticking with that.
You can't keep making new noises that I
have to make with my face.
They make you feel better about yourself
because if that's all it takes for you
to feel better about yourself is people
call you a new noise.
That's ridiculous.
If I decide tomorrow,
my,
my new name is Sheila,
I want everybody to call me Sheila.
But you just laughed.
That's a micro aggression.
There is a microaggression.
Why wide?
What?
Joe is a boring ass fucking stupid name
and I've got stuck with that boring ass
stupid name.
This is how boring ass stupid.
My Dad's name is Joe.
My grandfather's name is Joe.
My grandmother's name is Josephine.
Bunch of fucking unoriginal,
uncreative fucks in my family.
So what,
it's just a noise that you make with
your face when you say,
hey joe to me and my,
my friend Joey is right behind me and I
don't know which Joe after look.
Oh No,
you've,
you've microaggressed me again cause I
don't know what Joe you're referring to.
This is a noise that you make that
represents you.
Who gives a shit?
Is it,
those are some noises.
They're feminine.
There was some noises that are
ambiguous,
right?
You know,
like it's Pat,
remember that?
I'm not fucking show.
We couldn't figure out what gender she
was.
There's women named shelly,
there's men named shelly.
Fuck,
what are we,
Chris.
Christine.
There's genes that are girls and genes
that are guides.
So,
so confusing.
So you see how crazy that is?
It is confusing.
But here's what makes it worse.
What makes it worse is that if you make
a mistake,
there's,
there's a rule to punish you.
Like right now you have your operating
freely.
You have no rules.
People in people out that their pr,
they're paranoid.
They're paranoid about making a mistake.
So of course,
I mean that's just the way it is.
I mean,
when,
when you have a bunch of people that are
hypersensitive and that are trying to
enforce these ridiculous ideas on people
and they're trying to pound these things
down,
they're looking for these moments with
aiken solidify.
This is the moment.
So they could point at you these moments
where I call them green lights are
called them green lights because they
might not be upset.
They might not really be upset,
but they have a green light to act
upset.
Yeah,
there's their battery.
You know,
my whole buffalo battery,
that's where I found one.
And they have community support because
now the victim is the highest level.
Yeah.
And they're all social retards.
The other part of the problem,
and I say retards,
he'll like,
you know,
it's politically incorrect.
Word retarded means slowed.
And the that is socially retarded to
like operate this way.
It's,
it's,
it's slows everything down.
It's,
it's awkward.
It's confusing.
It's not necessary.
What's necessary is friendship,
kindness,
compassion,
open mindedness.
And those things don't exist when you
were pointing fingers at people.
Right.
And shaming them over innocuous things.
Like you,
Oh,
you called her a she on Thursday,
right?
You fuck she's he on Thursday.
Right.
Come on in.
And this is nonsense that acts against
their own interest.
That creates adversary relationships.
Cause then you're like,
oh,
Caitlin.
You know,
could you just make them socially
spoiled?
I mean,
that's what you're doing.
That's exactly what you're doing.
Yeah.
We're out of time.
All right,
cool.
Fucking hammered it out for three hours.
I don't say we've changed the Goddamn
thing about the world,
but a three hour thing.
Yes we did.
We just did three hours.
Well,
thank you Peter.
I really appreciate it.
If people want to find you on twitter,
it's a Peter Boghossian,
he's probably gonna be fired from his
job at Portland State University after
this podcast.
So please,
uh,
you know,
open up a patrion page and that's the
request I call those social justice
freaks.
Anything else?
Thank you.
I appreciate.
Let's do this again.
This is a lot of fun.
Thanks.
All right,
Peter Goes,
the young ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back at 2:00 PM with the
fighter and the kid,
Brian Cowen and Brendan Schaub.
We're going to have a UFC one 94 recap.
Holla.
Yeah.